I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi, lady. I'm excited for today.
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi, lady. I'm excited for today.|||I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. 我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正为你带来终极的“办公室爱人”播客。每周我们都会深入探讨《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事。我们是Office Ladies 6.0。嗨，女士。我很期待今天的内容。
I'm so thrilled and giddy. I'm actually like having the little body buzz. We're doing an All About episode. episode, everyone. As you know, these All About episodes, we focus on a specific character from the show. We really deep dive into them. They were my friend Angela Kinsey's idea. Thanks, lady. You said, I have this idea. We do these episodes where we dive into a character that's called All About Fill in the blank. I wish people could see you right now, because your impression of me is very jazz hands. Well, you've got an idea. You've got a vision. I don't know why you've suddenly become like a director
I'm so thrilled and giddy. I'm actually like having the little body buzz. We're doing an All About episode. episode, everyone. As you know, these All About episodes, we focus on a specific character from the show. We really deep dive into them. They were my friend Angela Kinsey's idea. Thanks, lady. You said, I have this idea. We do these episodes where we dive into a character that's called All About Fill in the blank. I wish people could see you right now, because your impression of me is very jazz hands. Well, you've got an idea. You've got a vision. I don't know why you've suddenly become like a director|||我太兴奋、太开心了。我甚至浑身都有点发麻。大家知道，我们要出一期“全方位解析”节目。如你们所知，这些全方位解析节目中，我们会聚焦剧中的某个特定角色。我们会对他们进行深入剖析。这是我的朋友安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）提出的主意。谢谢你，女士。你说过，我有个主意。我们做这样的节目，深入剖析一个角色，叫做“全方位解析：某某”。我真希望大家现在能看见你，因为你模仿我的样子非常有爵士手势的感觉。好吧，你有个想法。你有个愿景。我不知道为什么你突然变得像个导演一样
from the 1920s, but that's how I'm doing you. Well, I'd like to kick things off with this letter that we got from Lauren W. in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania. Who said, hi, Jenna and Angela. I'm sure I'm not the first person to suggest this, so I'll add my name to the list. We need an All About Jan episode. Malora Hardin is absolutely amazing, and the character of Jan Levinson is one of the most brilliant creations in TV history.
from the 1920s, but that's how I'm doing you. Well, I'd like to kick things off with this letter that we got from Lauren W. in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania. Who said, hi, Jenna and Angela. I'm sure I'm not the first person to suggest this, so I'll add my name to the list. We need an All About Jan episode. Malora Hardin is absolutely amazing, and the character of Jan Levinson is one of the most brilliant creations in TV history.|||来自20世纪20年代，不过我就是这么演你的。好了，我想以这封来自宾夕法尼亚州费城的劳伦·W.（Lauren W.）的信来拉开序幕。她说，嗨，珍娜和安吉拉。我确信我不是第一个提出这个建议的人，所以我也把我的名字加到这个名单里。我们需要一期关于简（Jan）的全方位解析节目。梅洛拉·哈丁（Melora Hardin）绝对太棒了，而简·莱文森（Jan Levinson）这个角色是电视史上最辉煌的创作之一。
Well, Lauren, we couldn't agree. with you more. A hundred percent. So today is all about Jan Levinson. Gold. Without the gold. Yes, exactly. Okay, so normally our all about character breakdowns, we pick an area of interest to discuss about that particular character. But we're going to do this episode a little differently because Lauren, many people, just like you, wanted an all about Jan. In fact, when we put up our folder for questions, we got so many. And we thought, you know what? Let's just take them right to the source and ask Malora. She is going to join us to answer them all, and we don't want to waste any more time.
Well, Lauren, we couldn't agree. with you more. A hundred percent. So today is all about Jan Levinson. Gold. Without the gold. Yes, exactly. Okay, so normally our all about character breakdowns, we pick an area of interest to discuss about that particular character. But we're going to do this episode a little differently because Lauren, many people, just like you, wanted an all about Jan. In fact, when we put up our folder for questions, we got so many. And we thought, you know what? Let's just take them right to the source and ask Malora. She is going to join us to answer them all, and we don't want to waste any more time.|||劳伦，我们不能再同意你更多了。百分之百同意。所以今天的主题就是简·莱文森。黄金。没有“戈德（Gold）”的。对，完全正确。好吧，通常在我们的全方位角色剖析中，我们会挑选一个感兴趣的领域来讨论那个特定的角色。但我们这期节目要稍微做点不同的尝试，因为劳伦，还有许多人和你一样，都想要一期关于简的节目。事实上，当我们发布收集问题的文件夹时，我们收到了超级多。然后我们想，你知道吗？不如我们直接去找源头，问问梅洛拉。她将加入我们来回答所有这些问题，我们不想再浪费时间了。
There is so much to talk about. Yes. As you all know, we had her on the podcast when we broke down the client in season two. She told us how she got her job as Jan and a whole bunch of other fun stuff. Definitely give it a listen if you missed it. She is such a great storyteller, and we're so excited to have her back on the podcast because now she's going to answer even more questions about her time on the show. show. But first, we got a letter, Ethan G from France, who said, we know that you have lots of
There is so much to talk about. Yes. As you all know, we had her on the podcast when we broke down the client in season two. She told us how she got her job as Jan and a whole bunch of other fun stuff. Definitely give it a listen if you missed it. She is such a great storyteller, and we're so excited to have her back on the podcast because now she's going to answer even more questions about her time on the show. show. But first, we got a letter, Ethan G from France, who said, we know that you have lots of|||有太多事情可以聊了。是的。正如大家所知，我们在第二季解析《客户》那一期时，曾邀请她上过播客。她告诉了我们她是如何得到简这个角色的，以及一堆其他有趣的事情。如果你错过了，一定要去听听。她是个极佳的故事讲述者，我们非常高兴能再次邀请她回到播客中，因为这次她将回答更多关于她在剧中时光的问题。不过首先，我们收到了一封信，来自法国的伊森·G.（Ethan G.）说，我们知道你们在
information in the show Bible about characters. What does the show Bible say about Jan? I mean, it wouldn't be an all about without a show Bible moment. Exactly. So I looked it up, and here's what I got for you, Ethan. First of all, according to Michael, her name is Janet. Jan is short for Janet. Jan smokes or smells her candles when she, stressed out. She's stressed out a lot. Yeah. Jan claims to be good at public speaking. We don't ever really see this, but she does do a good job of shutting down the idea of unionizing in the warehouse. Yeah. According to Michael, she's a great limbo dancer. Jan does not like Dwight. The showbubal says that. Jan does not like Dwight. Also, Jan hates that Dwight has her cell phone number.
information in the show Bible about characters. What does the show Bible say about Jan? I mean, it wouldn't be an all about without a show Bible moment. Exactly. So I looked it up, and here's what I got for you, Ethan. First of all, according to Michael, her name is Janet. Jan is short for Janet. Jan smokes or smells her candles when she, stressed out. She's stressed out a lot. Yeah. Jan claims to be good at public speaking. We don't ever really see this, but she does do a good job of shutting down the idea of unionizing in the warehouse. Yeah. According to Michael, she's a great limbo dancer. Jan does not like Dwight. The showbubal says that. Jan does not like Dwight. Also, Jan hates that Dwight has her cell phone number.|||剧本圣经里有很多关于角色的信息。剧本圣经里对简是怎么说的？我的意思是，如果没有剧本圣经的环节，就不算是一期真正的全方位解析了。没错。所以我查了一下，伊森，我为你找到了这些。首先，根据迈克尔的说法，她的名字叫珍妮特（Janet）。简是珍妮特的简称。简在感到压力大时会抽烟或闻蜡烛。她经常压力山大。是的。简声称自己擅长公开演讲。我们其实从未真正见过她公开演讲，但她在仓库阻止工会化这件事上确实做得不错。是的。根据迈克尔的说法，她是个出色的林波舞者。简不喜欢德 Dwight。剧本圣经上是这么说的。简不喜欢德怀特。此外，简讨厌德怀特有她的手机号码。
She likes blouses from Liz Claiborne and earrings from Anne Taylor. So specific. Mm-hmm. She is divorced and was a victim of identity theft all in the same year. She sees a psychiatrist who believes she has some self-destructive tendencies. She often drinks heavily. She specifically likes martinis. She also ordered a vodka tonic, I watched.
She likes blouses from Liz Claiborne and earrings from Anne Taylor. So specific. Mm-hmm. She is divorced and was a victim of identity theft all in the same year. She sees a psychiatrist who believes she has some self-destructive tendencies. She often drinks heavily. She specifically likes martinis. She also ordered a vodka tonic, I watched.|||她喜欢莉兹·克莱本（Liz Claiborne）的衬衫和安泰勒（Anne Taylor）的耳环. 太具体了。嗯哼。她离过婚，并在同一年遭遇了身份盗窃。她看了一位精神科医生，医生认为她有一些自毁倾向。她经常酗酒。她特别喜欢马提尼。我还看到她点过伏特加汤力水。
It said, in the show Bible, she makes her assistant buy her vodka. She also missed her yoga class because she drank too. much. Jan eventually dates Michael and moves in with him but has never told him she loves him. She enjoys videotaping their sex. She got breast implants but complains she has lost nipple sensitivity. I can't believe that is in the show Bible. She likes scrapbooking and soy milk. I didn't see scrapbooking coming. After breaking up with Michael, she becomes pregnant after going to a sperm bank. She becomes a single mother to a little girl records Adores Day cover album. Then she works as a hospital administrator before becoming an executive at the White Pages
It said, in the show Bible, she makes her assistant buy her vodka. She also missed her yoga class because she drank too. much. Jan eventually dates Michael and moves in with him but has never told him she loves him. She enjoys videotaping their sex. She got breast implants but complains she has lost nipple sensitivity. I can't believe that is in the show Bible. She likes scrapbooking and soy milk. I didn't see scrapbooking coming. After breaking up with Michael, she becomes pregnant after going to a sperm bank. She becomes a single mother to a little girl records Adores Day cover album. Then she works as a hospital administrator before becoming an executive at the White Pages|||上面写着，剧本圣经里提到，她让助手给她买伏特加。她还因为喝得太多而错过了瑜伽课。简最终和迈克尔约会并搬去和他一起住，但从未对他说过我爱你。她喜欢把他们做爱的过程录成视频。她做过隆胸手术，但抱怨说乳头失去了敏感度。我真不敢相信剧本圣经里会有这个。她喜欢做剪贴簿和喝豆浆。我没想到她会喜欢做剪贴簿。与迈克尔分手后，她通过精子库怀孕了。她成为了一名小女孩的单亲妈妈，还录制了Adores Day的翻唱专辑。后来她做过医院行政人员，之后成为White Pages的高管
and starting a sexual relationship with Clark. We know she refuses to give Dunder Mifflin the White Pages account and that Dwight does eventually get them, but not much is known about what happens to Jan after that. That is what the show Bible had to say. Well, I loved all the nuggets in there. There was some good nuggets. Real specific stuff. I know.
and starting a sexual relationship with Clark. We know she refuses to give Dunder Mifflin the White Pages account and that Dwight does eventually get them, but not much is known about what happens to Jan after that. That is what the show Bible had to say. Well, I loved all the nuggets in there. There was some good nuggets. Real specific stuff. I know.|||并与克拉克（Clark）开始了一段性关系。我们知道她拒绝把White Pages的客户给邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin），而且德怀特最终确实拿到了，但关于简在那之后发生了什么，大家知之甚少。这就是剧本圣经里所记载的。好吧，我喜欢里面所有的干货。里面有一些不错的干货。非常具体的内容。我知道。
And before we chat with Malora, you know, we do this for all the all-abouts. We have to have our favorite Jan moments from the office ladies team. Jenna, why don't you go first? Well, I love her speech to Michael in season three back from vacation. I love it so much. Here it is. Why am I here, Michael? In the last year, I've gone through a divorce, an identity theft, a husband who would not communicate.
And before we chat with Malora, you know, we do this for all the all-abouts. We have to have our favorite Jan moments from the office ladies team. Jenna, why don't you go first? Well, I love her speech to Michael in season three back from vacation. I love it so much. Here it is. Why am I here, Michael? In the last year, I've gone through a divorce, an identity theft, a husband who would not communicate.|||在和梅洛拉聊天之前，你知道的，我们每期全方位解析都会这样做。我们办公室女士团队必须分享我们最喜欢的简的时刻。珍娜，你先来吧？好吧，我非常喜欢她在第三季度假回来后对迈克尔说的那番话。我太喜欢了。就是这段。为什么我要来这里，迈克尔？在过去的这一年里，我经历了一场离婚，一次身份盗窃，还有一个不肯沟通的丈夫。
This is neither here nor there. My psychiatrist thinks that I have some self-destructive tendencies, and that for once I should indulge them. You following me? Uh, yes. I think I owe it to myself to find some kind of happiness. You know, I mean, even if it means lowering my expectations or redefining the word itself.
This is neither here nor there. My psychiatrist thinks that I have some self-destructive tendencies, and that for once I should indulge them. You following me? Uh, yes. I think I owe it to myself to find some kind of happiness. You know, I mean, even if it means lowering my expectations or redefining the word itself.|||这些都不重要。我的精神科医生认为我有某种自毁倾向，而且我应该破例纵容自己一次。你听懂了吗？呃，是的。我觉得我欠自己一个去寻找某种幸福的机会。你知道的，我的意思是，哪怕这意味着降低我的期望，或者重新定义幸福这个词本身。
Okay, yeah. This is the thing. You know, I am attracted to you. I don't know why, but I am, and I need to follow my instincts. At least that's what Dr. Perry thinks. I was Dr. Perry. This is the point. Okay, you're wrong for me.
Okay, yeah. This is the thing. You know, I am attracted to you. I don't know why, but I am, and I need to follow my instincts. At least that's what Dr. Perry thinks. I was Dr. Perry. This is the point. Okay, you're wrong for me.|||好吧，对。事情是这样的。你知道，我被你吸引了。我不知道为什么，但我就是被吸引了，我需要顺从我的直觉。至少佩里医生是这么认为的。我就是佩里医生。这就是重点。好吧，你对我不合适。
Okay. In every way. But I still find myself wanting to be with you. I love how she can barely get out, be with you. She can barely say it. There's this big pause, and then it just comes out, be with you. Be with you. All right, Matt, how about yours?
Okay. In every way. But I still find myself wanting to be with you. I love how she can barely get out, be with you. She can barely say it. There's this big pause, and then it just comes out, be with you. Be with you. All right, Matt, how about yours?|||好吧。在各方面都不合适。但我发现自己还是想和你在一起。我太喜欢她几乎说不出口“和你在一起”的样子了。她几乎说不出口。中间停顿了很久，然后才说出来，和你在一起。和你在一起。好了，马特（Matt），你的呢？
Do you have a Jan favorite moment? I do. I love the character of Jan. This is such a great performance. And I pick the clip from The Client in season two when she's at the Chili's with Michael and Tim Meadows, the client. I just love this scene. She's just stuck with them. They're like doing their baby Vax rib song,
Do you have a Jan favorite moment? I do. I love the character of Jan. This is such a great performance. And I pick the clip from The Client in season two when she's at the Chili's with Michael and Tim Meadows, the client. I just love this scene. She's just stuck with them. They're like doing their baby Vax rib song,|||你有最喜欢的简的时刻吗？我有。我非常喜欢简这个角色。这表演太棒了。我选的是第二季《客户》里的一段剪辑，当时她和迈克尔以及客户蒂姆·梅多斯（Tim Meadows）在Chili's餐厅。我太喜欢这个场景了。她被困在他们中间。他们在那儿唱着他们那个“宝贝Vax排骨”之歌，
and she just so doesn't want to be there, but it's just like being a good sport and playing along. So I chose this clip from that scene. Well, this brings us to Jan, truth or dare. Tell us about your divorce. Oh, no, Michael. Michael, right? Michael, please.
and she just so doesn't want to be there, but it's just like being a good sport and playing along. So I chose this clip from that scene. Well, this brings us to Jan, truth or dare. Tell us about your divorce. Oh, no, Michael. Michael, right? Michael, please.|||而她极其不情愿待在那儿，但又表现得很大度、陪着他们一起玩。所以我选了那个场景里的这段剪辑。好了，这就让我们来到了简的“真心话大冒险”。跟我们讲讲你的离婚吧。哦，不，迈克尔。迈克尔，对吧？迈克尔，求你了。
No. Oh, really. Hey, so you're not gonna play. She's not playing. She's not playing the game. We've been fighting for a while. He didn't want kids. I knew that going into it,
No. Oh, really. Hey, so you're not gonna play. She's not playing. She's not playing the game. We've been fighting for a while. He didn't want kids. I knew that going into it,|||不。哦，真的吗。嘿，所以你是不打算玩了。她不玩了。她不玩这个游戏。我们吵了一段时间。他想要孩子。我一开始就知道这点，
but he also knew that I did. So I guess I thought. that he would change his mind, he thought that I would change mine. You didn't. I was stupid. No, no, you were not stupid. Gould was stupid, right? That's right.
but he also knew that I did. So I guess I thought. that he would change his mind, he thought that I would change mine. You didn't. I was stupid. No, no, you were not stupid. Gould was stupid, right? That's right.|||但他也很清楚我想要。所以我想我当时以为他会改变主意，他也以为我会改变我的主意。你没有。我很蠢。不，不，你一点也不蠢。戈德才蠢，对吧？没毛病。
You were really brave. I mean, you put your arms out there, you slit your wrist. That's true. You said, world, this is my blood. It's red, just like yours. So love me. The look she gives after he says that. She's like, what?
You were really brave. I mean, you put your arms out there, you slit your wrist. That's true. You said, world, this is my blood. It's red, just like yours. So love me. The look she gives after he says that. She's like, what?|||你真的很勇敢。我是说，你把手臂伸出去，你割了手腕。确实如此。你说，世界，这就是我的血。它是红色的，和你们的一样。所以爱我吧。当他说完那句话后，她露出的那个表情。她的表情就像是，什么鬼？
That is like a trio that I could watch all day. It's so good. The line I quote most from the office is also a Jan line from dinner party when Pam brings her the bottle of wine. She goes, oh, great, I'll use this to cook with. This will be great for cooking. Yeah, I say that anytime someone gives me a bottle of wine. Sam, do you have one? Yes, I do.
That is like a trio that I could watch all day. It's so good. The line I quote most from the office is also a Jan line from dinner party when Pam brings her the bottle of wine. She goes, oh, great, I'll use this to cook with. This will be great for cooking. Yeah, I say that anytime someone gives me a bottle of wine. Sam, do you have one? Yes, I do.|||那真的是一个我可以看一整天的铁三角。太棒了。我在《办公室》里引用最多的台词也是简的一句台词，出自《晚宴》那一集，当时潘（Pam）给她带了一瓶酒。她说，哦，太好了，我要用这个来做饭。这个用来做饭太棒了。对，每当有人送我一瓶酒，我都会这么说。萨姆（Sam），你有一个吗？是的，我有。
I think it's a good example of her playing both a straight, and the ridiculous character. It's where Jan pulls Michael into the bathroom of David Wallace's house. Here we go. Like your privacy. Shut up. What is coming into you? No, no, no, no.
I think it's a good example of her playing both a straight, and the ridiculous character. It's where Jan pulls Michael into the bathroom of David Wallace's house. Here we go. Like your privacy. Shut up. What is coming into you? No, no, no, no.|||我认为这是一个很好的例子，展现了她如何同时扮演正经角色和滑稽角色。就是简把迈克尔拉进大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）家卫生间的那个场景。我们开始了。喜欢你们的隐私。闭嘴。你到底在发什么疯？不，不，不，不。
Come on, let's go back to the party. Come on, wait. We're missing. Don't take that. No, stop it. Stop it. Jan. No, no, no.
Come on, let's go back to the party. Come on, wait. We're missing. Don't take that. No, stop it. Stop it. Jan. No, no, no.|||来吧，我们回派对去。来吧，等等。我们错过了。别拿那个。不，住手。住手。简。不，不，不。
No means, please don't. Seems, I'm not going to slam you against anything. You're acting inappropriate. Jan. I'm acting inappropriate. Yeah. Forget it. Get out of my way. Oh.
No means, please don't. Seems, I'm not going to slam you against anything. You're acting inappropriate. Jan. I'm acting inappropriate. Yeah. Forget it. Get out of my way. Oh.|||不就是“请不要”的意思。听着，我又不会把你撞到什么东西上去。你的举止很不恰当。简。我举止很不恰当。哼。算了。给我让开。哦。
Yeah, it's great. She just has to play both the ridiculous character and the straight man character at once. It's great. The two of them are so good together. So good together. No, she's like spiraling. And so she's going to her default, which is just... Hookup.
Yeah, it's great. She just has to play both the ridiculous character and the straight man character at once. It's great. The two of them are so good together. So good together. No, she's like spiraling. And so she's going to her default, which is just... Hookup.|||对，太棒了。她必须同时扮演滑稽角色和正经角色。太棒了。他们俩在一起真是绝配。真是绝配。不，她当时的状态就像是在失控下坠。所以她回归到了她的默认模式，那就是……上床。
Just he's... Michael has enraged her, and then it just like turns into just, she's turned on. I know. Yeah. Which is very funny because there's the whole runner with you. and Andy planning your wedding on the show. And every time Andy bothers the character of Angela with like wedding plans, then she pages Dwight for sex.
Just he's... Michael has enraged her, and then it just like turns into just, she's turned on. I know. Yeah. Which is very funny because there's the whole runner with you. and Andy planning your wedding on the show. And every time Andy bothers the character of Angela with like wedding plans, then she pages Dwight for sex.|||就是他……迈克尔惹恼了她，然后事情就变成了，她被点燃了。我知道。是的。这非常搞笑，因为剧中有一条贯穿始终的副线，是你和安迪（Andy）在筹备婚礼。每次安迪用婚礼筹划之类的事情去烦安吉拉这个角色时，她就会呼叫德怀特来做爱。
I know. This is like kind of a common theme in the show. How like how people deal with stress. Exactly. They sex it up. Well, Angela, what about you? Well, I rewatched some compilation like videos of Jan scenes. They were such a joy.
I know. This is like kind of a common theme in the show. How like how people deal with stress. Exactly. They sex it up. Well, Angela, what about you? Well, I rewatched some compilation like videos of Jan scenes. They were such a joy.|||我知道。这在剧中算是一个挺常见的桥段了。比如人们如何应对压力。没错。他们通过做爱来宣泄。好吧，安吉拉，你呢？嗯，我重看了一些简的场景的剪辑视频。它们真的太带劲了。
By the way, did you guys know there's a YouTube montage just titled Jan being a walking red flag for 36 minutes straight. I saw that. That's great. That's the title of it, which is what's amazing. So her performances are all amazing, but season three is really a stellar Jan season, and my clip is from The Job. So it starts at the corporate offices. David Wallace has just fired Jan.
By the way, did you guys know there's a YouTube montage just titled Jan being a walking red flag for 36 minutes straight. I saw that. That's great. That's the title of it, which is what's amazing. So her performances are all amazing, but season three is really a stellar Jan season, and my clip is from The Job. So it starts at the corporate offices. David Wallace has just fired Jan.|||顺便问一下，你们知道YouTube上有一个蒙太奇视频，标题就叫“简连续36分钟成为行走的红旗”吗？我看到了。太棒了。标题就是这个，这才是绝妙之处。所以她的表演都非常惊艳，但第三季绝对是简的高光赛季，我的片段来自《工作》。故事从公司总部开始。大卫·华莱士刚刚解雇了简。
She's called him a son of a bitch. She says goodbye to Hunter, wishes him all the best with his band, and then she's going to hop in the car with Michael. She's starting to really spiral, and you got to hear it. Oh, God. I mean, I just don't understand. It's just so rude, you know? I mean, the absolute nerve of that guy. I'm sorry about that. That was terrible. No, actually, I think it's good. You know, it's fine, actually. I do. I really think it's great that it happened because, you know, my work has always been the thing that's gotten in the way of my happiness, so. Well, it's...
She's called him a son of a bitch. She says goodbye to Hunter, wishes him all the best with his band, and then she's going to hop in the car with Michael. She's starting to really spiral, and you got to hear it. Oh, God. I mean, I just don't understand. It's just so rude, you know? I mean, the absolute nerve of that guy. I'm sorry about that. That was terrible. No, actually, I think it's good. You know, it's fine, actually. I do. I really think it's great that it happened because, you know, my work has always been the thing that's gotten in the way of my happiness, so. Well, it's...|||她骂他是个混蛋。她向亨特（Hunter）告别，祝他的乐队一切顺利，然后她准备坐上迈克尔的车。她开始真正失控了，你们得听听这个。哦，天哪。我是说，我就是不明白。这太粗鲁了，你知道吗？我是说，那家伙的脸皮可真厚。我很抱歉听到这个。太糟糕了。不，其实我觉得挺好的。你知道的，其实挺好的。真的。我真的觉得发生这种事挺好的，因为，你知道的，我的工作一直都是阻碍我获得幸福的绊脚石，所以。嗯，这……
No, don't cry. It's gonna be okay. Oh, I know, I know. I'm sorry. I just... Sorry, these painkillers that I started taking since the surgery. Oh, they make my moods totally unpredictable. Wow. What am I going to do? Well, I guess you could come to save my condo. I think I could get back out of the sale.
No, don't cry. It's gonna be okay. Oh, I know, I know. I'm sorry. I just... Sorry, these painkillers that I started taking since the surgery. Oh, they make my moods totally unpredictable. Wow. What am I going to do? Well, I guess you could come to save my condo. I think I could get back out of the sale.|||不，别哭。会好起来的。哦，我知道，我知道。对不起。我只是……抱歉，我自从手术后开始吃这些止痛药。哦，它们让我的情绪变得完全捉摸不定。哇。我该怎么办？嗯，我想你可以搬来我的公寓。我想我可以取消这栋房子的出售。
Probably get some negative feedback on my eBay profile. Live together. Actually, wait a minute. This could be great. This could be perfect. You know, my full-time job can be our relationship. I could wear stretch pants and wait for you to come home at 515. It could work.
Probably get some negative feedback on my eBay profile. Live together. Actually, wait a minute. This could be great. This could be perfect. You know, my full-time job can be our relationship. I could wear stretch pants and wait for you to come home at 515. It could work.|||我的eBay账号可能会收到一些差评。住在一起。其实，等一下。这太棒了。这简直完美。你知道的，我的全职工作就可以是我们的恋爱关系。我可以穿着紧身裤，等着你5点15分回家。这行得通。
This could work, really. Oh my gosh. There's so many highs and lows. The journey through that. Yes. Like she's pissed off. Then she starts crying. Then she's like, this could work.
This could work, really. Oh my gosh. There's so many highs and lows. The journey through that. Yes. Like she's pissed off. Then she starts crying. Then she's like, this could work.|||这真的行得通。哦，天哪。起伏太跌宕起伏了。经历这个过程就像……是的。比如她先是气急败坏。然后她开始哭泣。接着她又觉得，这行得通。
And she's like, this is great. Oh, could you imagine a whole life with someone who turns on a dime so quickly like that? And Michael's face as she's going through all that is like, oh, no. It's like the roles have reversed. First. Yes. Now he's like, okay, I'm going to do this. Amazing.
And she's like, this is great. Oh, could you imagine a whole life with someone who turns on a dime so quickly like that? And Michael's face as she's going through all that is like, oh, no. It's like the roles have reversed. First. Yes. Now he's like, okay, I'm going to do this. Amazing.|||然后她又说，这太棒了。哦，你能想象和一个情绪说变就变的人共度一生是什么样的吗？而当她经历这一切时，迈克尔的表情就像是，哦，不。这就像是两人的角色对调了。一开始。是的。现在他觉得，好吧，我要这么做了。太绝了。
Guys, this has gotten me very excited. I think we should take a break because when we come back, we will have Malora Hardin in studio answering all of your Jan questions. I can't wait. Welcome back to office ladies, Malora. Thank you so much. It's great to see you guys. I know.
Guys, this has gotten me very excited. I think we should take a break because when we come back, we will have Malora Hardin in studio answering all of your Jan questions. I can't wait. Welcome back to office ladies, Malora. Thank you so much. It's great to see you guys. I know.|||伙计们，这让我太兴奋了。我想我们应该休息一下，因为等我们回来后，梅洛拉·哈丁将做客我们的演播室，回答你们关于简的所有问题。我等不及了。欢迎回到《办公室女士》，梅洛拉。非常感谢。很高兴见到你们。我知道。
We're in person. This is super fun. In person. We should confess that we have been chatting for close to 30 minutes. We're coming on Mike. It has just been an absolute delight. It has been so nice to see you both. I haven't seen you in person in a really long time.
We're in person. This is super fun. In person. We should confess that we have been chatting for close to 30 minutes. We're coming on Mike. It has just been an absolute delight. It has been so nice to see you both. I haven't seen you in person in a really long time.|||我们是面对面录制。这太有趣了。面对面。我们必须坦白，我们已经聊了将近30分钟了。我们才刚打开麦克风。这简直是一种纯粹的享受。见到你们俩太好了。我已经很久很久没有在线下见到你们了。
I know. Yeah. It's really nice. Yeah. I am thankful, though, that the cast, like, we will text or DM. I just am so appreciative of the little touchstones we have every once in a while in each other's lives. Yeah, it's good. It's sweet.
I know. Yeah. It's really nice. Yeah. I am thankful, though, that the cast, like, we will text or DM. I just am so appreciative of the little touchstones we have every once in a while in each other's lives. Yeah, it's good. It's sweet.|||我知道。是的。真的很好。是的。不过我很感激，剧组演员之间，我们还会发短信或私信。我非常珍视我们在彼此生活中偶尔能有的那些微小交集。是的，这很好。很温馨。
Well, I'm rewatching the office now with my kids. Oh, wow. They're on their first watch of it. We've just gotten to season five. So you've been on my TV every night, basically. as we go through the show. So I feel like I just saw you. I need to do that.
Well, I'm rewatching the office now with my kids. Oh, wow. They're on their first watch of it. We've just gotten to season five. So you've been on my TV every night, basically. as we go through the show. So I feel like I just saw you. I need to do that.|||嗯，我现在正和我的孩子们一起重看《办公室》。哦，哇。他们是第一次看这部剧。我们刚看到第五季。所以基本上我们看剧的时候，你每天晚上都在我的电视上。所以我感觉我好像刚见过你。我也得这么做。
You know, I haven't seen the show since it aired. Oh, Malora, you are so phenomenal. Isn't that weird? You need to watch it. I don't think it's weird. I literally have not. If we didn't do this podcast, I'm not sure I would have sat down and watched it.
You know, I haven't seen the show since it aired. Oh, Malora, you are so phenomenal. Isn't that weird? You need to watch it. I don't think it's weird. I literally have not. If we didn't do this podcast, I'm not sure I would have sat down and watched it.|||你知道吗，自从这部剧播出以来，我还没看过它呢。哦，梅洛拉，你太神了。这不是很奇怪吗？你应该去看看。我不觉得奇怪。我真的没看。如果我们不做这个播客，我不确定我是否会坐下来看它。
And now my kids' curiosity, that's why I'm watching it again. Right, right, yeah. I watched it with my kids too. My kids watched it, but I didn't watch it with them, but I should have. That's a really good idea that you did that. You're doing it together. Well, first of all, like Jenna said, we did the whole rewatch.
And now my kids' curiosity, that's why I'm watching it again. Right, right, yeah. I watched it with my kids too. My kids watched it, but I didn't watch it with them, but I should have. That's a really good idea that you did that. You're doing it together. Well, first of all, like Jenna said, we did the whole rewatch.|||现在是因为孩子们的好奇心，我才又看了一遍。对的，对的，是的。我也和我的孩子们一起看了。我的孩子们看了，但我没有和他们一起看，不过我本该一起看的。你这样做真的是个好主意。你们是一起看的。嗯，首先，就像珍娜说的，我们做完了整部剧的重看。
But then I spent last night just watching all of your stuff, like the best of Jan, kind of all these like clips. And you are just so brilliant. And I want you to rewatch it just to watch how great Jan is because you have created the most amazing character. And you should know, and I know you must know this, that you are on the fan favorite list of like office characters. Oh, I love that.
But then I spent last night just watching all of your stuff, like the best of Jan, kind of all these like clips. And you are just so brilliant. And I want you to rewatch it just to watch how great Jan is because you have created the most amazing character. And you should know, and I know you must know this, that you are on the fan favorite list of like office characters. Oh, I love that.|||但昨晚我花时间专门看完了你所有的片段，比如“简的高光时刻”之类的所有这些剪辑。你真的太出色了。我真想让你也重看一遍，去看看简有多么伟大，因为你创造了最了不起的角色。而且你应该知道——我知道你肯定也知道——在粉丝最喜爱的《办公室》角色榜单上，绝对有你的名字。哦，我太喜欢这个了。
That's great. all the lists. Right, right. I love that. Well, I think the show was so amazingly well cast. You know what I mean? Yeah. I mean, everybody on the show was like perfect for who they played. Really, really perfect. It's always those lightning in a bottle kind of moments where people are like, what is it that made, you know, why did that movie? Why was that show? It's like all those things have to come together. And there really is no recipe for that. It is the writing. It is the casting. it is the directing, it is the lighting, it is the sets, it is the props. Like it all just has to like infuse into this little special magical moment and the fact
That's great. all the lists. Right, right. I love that. Well, I think the show was so amazingly well cast. You know what I mean? Yeah. I mean, everybody on the show was like perfect for who they played. Really, really perfect. It's always those lightning in a bottle kind of moments where people are like, what is it that made, you know, why did that movie? Why was that show? It's like all those things have to come together. And there really is no recipe for that. It is the writing. It is the casting. it is the directing, it is the lighting, it is the sets, it is the props. Like it all just has to like infuse into this little special magical moment and the fact|||太棒了。所有的榜单都在。对的，对的。我太喜欢了。嗯，我觉得这部剧的选角简直好得惊人。你知道我的意思吗？是的。我是说，剧中每个人都完美契合他们所扮演的角色。真的，非常完美。这总是那种“灵光乍现”的奇妙时刻，人们会问，究竟是什么让……你知道的，为什么那部电影会成功？为什么那部剧会成功？就好像所有这些元素必须完美融合在一起。这真的没有什么秘诀。是编剧，是选角，是导演，是灯光，是布景，是道具。这一切都必须融汇进这个特别的、充满魔力的时刻里，而且事实上
that we were part of something that is so special and that it's lived as long as it has and that people are still as enthusiastic about it as they are. Thanks to streaming and the fact that we can continue to have generations that are just discovering it now, it's extraordinary to have fans that are in their 60s and 70s. and fans that are 10. I know, right? It's really crazy. And I had been, you know, in this business since I was six years old.
that we were part of something that is so special and that it's lived as long as it has and that people are still as enthusiastic about it as they are. Thanks to streaming and the fact that we can continue to have generations that are just discovering it now, it's extraordinary to have fans that are in their 60s and 70s. and fans that are 10. I know, right? It's really crazy. And I had been, you know, in this business since I was six years old.|||我们曾是这样一个特别项目的一部分，它历经岁月却依然长青，人们对它的热情依旧不减当年。多亏了流媒体，以及不断有新一代观众在此时此刻发现这部剧，能拥有六七十岁的粉丝，也有十岁的粉丝，这真是太不可思议了。我懂，对吧？真的太疯狂了。而且我，你知道的，从六岁起就进入这个行业了。
And I think that when I did the office, I think I literally, I think it was my 13th pilot. And so I was really used to things just, you know, being on the air as long as they were on the air. And then that was it. Just going off the air or just getting put up on a shelf. No one ever seeing them or some people seeing them or maybe a few people seeing them or even when it was kind of like successful. But then it was over and that's it. You know, so this was all very shocking to me. Just where I was in my reality timeline of, you know, my age and stuff and in my life,
And I think that when I did the office, I think I literally, I think it was my 13th pilot. And so I was really used to things just, you know, being on the air as long as they were on the air. And then that was it. Just going off the air or just getting put up on a shelf. No one ever seeing them or some people seeing them or maybe a few people seeing them or even when it was kind of like successful. But then it was over and that's it. You know, so this was all very shocking to me. Just where I was in my reality timeline of, you know, my age and stuff and in my life,|||我想当我拍摄《办公室》的时候，这字面意义上可以说是我拍的第13部试播集了。所以我真的很习惯那些事情，你知道的，剧集播多久就播多久，然后就结束了。要么停播，要么被束之高阁。再也没有人看到它们，或者少数人看到，或者也许只有极少数人看到，甚至当它稍微有点成功的时候。但随后一切就结束了，仅此而已。你知道的，所以这一切对我来说都非常震撼。就我当时所处的人生现实时间线而言——你知道的，我的年龄和生活状态——
this was just a very unusual experience for me. I don't know if I told you guys about that one that I didn't even believe we were a hit. Did I tell you that? No. I didn't even, I was like, I didn't know we were a hit until we won the SAG Award. The first SAG Award. And I don't know if you remember. that trophy is made out of bronze, and then the base of it is just a solid brick of marble.
this was just a very unusual experience for me. I don't know if I told you guys about that one that I didn't even believe we were a hit. Did I tell you that? No. I didn't even, I was like, I didn't know we were a hit until we won the SAG Award. The first SAG Award. And I don't know if you remember. that trophy is made out of bronze, and then the base of it is just a solid brick of marble.|||这对我来说是一次非常不寻常的经历。我不知道我有没有跟你们说过那件事，就是我甚至不相信我们火了。我跟你们说过吗？没有。我甚至……我当时的想法是，直到我们赢得演员工会奖（SAG Award），我才知道我们火了。第一个演员工会奖。我不知道你们记不记得，那个奖杯是青铜做的，然后它的底座是一块厚实的大理石砖。
Marble. And when you are a winner, right, you walk around all night. You don't carry it like at your knee. You don't carry it above your head. You carry it with your elbow bent up here because everyone wants to see it. So you're kind of holding it like right at your shoulder, right? I woke up the next morning and I could not lift my arm. My bicep was just absolutely completely dead.
Marble. And when you are a winner, right, you walk around all night. You don't carry it like at your knee. You don't carry it above your head. You carry it with your elbow bent up here because everyone wants to see it. So you're kind of holding it like right at your shoulder, right? I woke up the next morning and I could not lift my arm. My bicep was just absolutely completely dead.|||大理石。当你成为获奖者时，对吧，你一整晚都拿着它到处走。你不会把它垂在膝盖旁拿著。你不会把它举过头顶。你会把手肘弯曲成这样拿着它，因为每个人都想看。所以你基本上是把它举在肩膀附近，对吧？第二天早上醒来，我的胳膊根本抬不起来了。我的二头肌完全彻底废了。
And I literally needed physical proof. I was like, oh, I guess that means we're hit. I mean, it was just that simple for me. I don't know whether it's the dancer in me or what, but I needed physical proof. That muscle memory of like, how this pain means it happens. Yes, it means I was carrying an award around all night and we are a hit. It was just surreal to me. Really surreal.
And I literally needed physical proof. I was like, oh, I guess that means we're hit. I mean, it was just that simple for me. I don't know whether it's the dancer in me or what, but I needed physical proof. That muscle memory of like, how this pain means it happens. Yes, it means I was carrying an award around all night and we are a hit. It was just surreal to me. Really surreal.|||我真的需要物理证据。我当时想，哦，看来这意味着我们火了。我的意思是，对我来说就是这么简单。我不知道是我骨子里的舞者特质还是什么原因，但我当时就需要物理证据。那种肌肉记忆，即这种疼痛意味着它发生了。是的，这意味着我整晚都拿着奖杯到处走，我们真的火了。这对我来说太超现实了。真的很超现实。
Anyway, sorry, you didn't even ask me one question and I went on a rant. This is what it is. This is what we love. So many people wrote in. We put out a prompt, hey, Malora's going to be on the show. Do you have any questions for Jan? Malora, we got so many amazing questions. Oh, good.
Anyway, sorry, you didn't even ask me one question and I went on a rant. This is what it is. This is what we love. So many people wrote in. We put out a prompt, hey, Malora's going to be on the show. Do you have any questions for Jan? Malora, we got so many amazing questions. Oh, good.|||总之，对不起，你们甚至还没问我一个问题，我就自顾自说了一大堆。这就是这样。这正是我们所爱的。有那么多人写信来。我们发出了一个提示，嘿，梅洛拉要上节目了。你们有什么问题想问简吗？梅洛拉，我们收到了太多精彩的问题了。哦，太好了。
So we're just going to throw a few at you today. Okay, good. Yeah, sure. Let's kick things off with Peyton W. from Hiram, Georgia, who said, when first starting the role, did Malora create any kind of character background apart from what was scripted in the show? And then Lisa R. from Plymouth Lake, California, said, what is Jan's history?
So we're just going to throw a few at you today. Okay, good. Yeah, sure. Let's kick things off with the letter from Peyton W. from Hiram, Georgia, who said, when first starting the role, did Malora create any kind of character background apart from what was scripted in the show? And then Lisa R. from Plymouth Lake, California, said, what is Jan's history?|||所以今天我们要向你抛出几个问题。好的，很好。好的，没问题。让我们从佐治亚州海勒姆（Hiram）的佩顿·W.（Peyton W.）的信开始吧，她问：刚开始演这个角色时，梅洛拉除了剧本写的内容之外，有没有为角色创作过任何背景故事？然后是加利福尼亚州普利茅斯湖（Plymouth Lake）的丽莎·R.（Lisa R.）问：简的过往经历是什么？
We first learn about her past at Chili's, but who is Mr. Gould? And what is that backstory? Did you create any kind of backstory for Jan? I don't think so. I don't remember that I did that. You know, Jan was so visceral to me. You know, Steve and I had such an interesting chemistry
We first learn about our past at Chili's, but who is Mr. Gould? And what is that backstory? Did you create any kind of backstory for Jan? I don't think so. I don't remember that I did that. You know, Jan was so visceral to me. You know, Steve and I had such an interesting chemistry|||我们第一次得知她的过去是在Chili's餐厅，但戈德先生是谁？那段背景故事是什么？你为简创作过什么背景故事吗？我想没有吧。我不记得我有做过那种事。你知道的，简对我的影响太深刻、太直观了。你知道，我和史蒂夫（Steve）之间有着非常有趣的化学反应，
that when we were playing the characters, there was such a distinct push-pulled. like attraction repulsion that was so visceral to me that I really just hooked into that. And I think that's really how Greg Daniels, the writers, you know, wrote, built the character was really from that sort of tactile kind of experience that I think the audience can feel and I think Steve and I could feel. And I remember saying it out loud at lunch during the pilot. I remember saying, you know, God, if we get picked up, Michael and Jan have to hook up somehow,
that when we were playing the characters, there was such a distinct push-pulled. like attraction repulsion that was so visceral to me that I really just hooked into that. And I think that's really how Greg Daniels, the writers, you know, wrote, built the character was really from that sort of tactile kind of experience that I think the audience can feel and I think Steve and I could feel. And I remember saying it out loud at lunch during the pilot. I remember saying, you know, God, if we get picked up, Michael and Jan have to hook up somehow,|||以至于当我们扮演这些角色时，那种推拉感——那种吸引与排斥——对我来说是如此直观，以至于我真的深深陷入其中。我想这也是格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）和编剧们如何构思、塑造这个角色的真正方式，它源于那种观众能感受到、我和史蒂夫也能感受到的切实体验。我记得在拍试播集吃午饭时，我曾大声说过这句话。我记得当时我说，天哪，如果我们被续订了，迈克尔和简无论如何都得搞在一起，
some way. And I remember Steve laughing and Greg laughing so hard and me laughing. And we were all just like, oh my God, that would be so wrong and so right. Like, we all just got it so early that I don't even think there was time to even think that way about this character, this role. I was hired as a guest star, possible recurring character in the pilot. I was not even necessarily going to be a regular on this show. I had done so many guests to our possible recurring characters in my career. So as far as like, is this going to be, you know, some memorable thing? I just was going in with this visceral feeling I had for her. And it seemed to be working. Everybody liked it. They were laughing. They were enjoying it. Steve and I had great
some way. And I remember Steve laughing and Greg laughing so hard and me laughing. And we were all just like, oh my God, that would be so wrong and so right. Like, we all just got it so early that I don't even think there was time to even think that way about this character, this role. I was hired as a guest star, possible recurring character in the pilot. I was not even necessarily going to be a regular on this show. I had done so many guests to our possible recurring characters in my career. So as far as like, is this going to be, you know, some memorable thing? I just was going in with this visceral feeling I had for her. And it seemed to be working. Everybody liked it. They were laughing. They were enjoying it. Steve and I had great|||无论用什么方法。我还记得史蒂夫在大笑，格雷格笑得前仰后合，我也在笑。我们当时都觉得，天哪，这既错得离谱又对得恰到好处。就像我们所有人都很早就心领神会了，以至于我甚至觉得当时根本没时间去深思这个角色。在试播集中，我被雇为客串演员，一个可能会常驻的角色。我甚至不一定是这部剧的固定演员。在我的职业生涯中，我演过太多这种客串或可能常驻的角色了。所以至于这会不会成为什么难忘的事情，我只是带着我对她的直观感觉走进了片场。而且这似乎很管用。大家都喜欢。他们在笑，他们很享受。我和史蒂夫有着极好的
chemistry when we were working together. And it was like, let's just go with this. Well, I, you know, a lot of people did write in about the chemistry. Okay. And Steve F from Brian, Texas said, do you remember a first or early moment on set that you knew you and Steve had great chemistry? It sounds like right from the pilot, but Steve wants you to know that your relationship on camera was truly remarkable. Oh, that's so nice. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I felt it. I think Steve and I both felt it really early. I have come from a background in improv, but different kind of improv than what Steve had come from. You know, my mother was an acting teacher, and she was an actress herself as a younger woman. And then she kind of put together her own technique, and she taught young people.
chemistry when we were working together. And it was like, let's just go with this. Well, I, you know, a lot of people did write in about the chemistry. Okay. And Steve F from Brian, Texas said, do you remember a first or early moment on set that you knew you and Steve had great chemistry? It sounds like right from the pilot, but Steve wants you to know that your relationship on camera was truly remarkable. Oh, that's so nice. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I felt it. I think Steve and I both felt it really early. I have come from a background in improv, but different kind of improv than what Steve had come from. You know, my mother was an acting teacher, and she was an actress herself as a younger woman. And then she kind of put together her own technique, and she taught young people.|||化学反应，当我们一起工作的时候。感觉就像是，我们就顺着这个感觉演下去吧。嗯，我知道，确实有很多人写信来谈到这种化学反应。好的。德克萨斯州布赖恩（Bryan）的史蒂夫·F.（Steve F.）问：你还记得片场哪个最初或早期的时刻，让你知道你和史蒂夫有着极好的化学反应吗？听起来从试播集就开始了，但史蒂夫想让你知道，你们在镜头前的关系真的很卓越。哦，这太暖心了。对的。是的。我是说，我感觉到了。我觉得我和史蒂夫都很早就感觉到了。我出身于即兴表演背景，但和史蒂夫的即兴表演风格有所不同。你知道的，我母亲是一名表演老师，她年轻时自己也是一名演员。后来她总结出了一套自己的表演技巧，并用来教年轻人。
She taught kids. Her name was Diane Hill Harden. She taught Leonardo DiCaprio when he was a kid and River Phoenix and Joaquin Phoenix and Maggie Jillon Hall and Jake Gyllenhall and Jessica Beale and, you know, on and on. But the point being that I think that the kind of improv I came from was really playing the truth. So not going for the laughs, but finding the comments. comedy inside the truth. So that was why, as a kid, actually, I think I was thought of mostly as a dramatic actress. And then as I got older and then, you know, comedy happened for me. People were
She taught kids. Her name was Diane Hill Harden. She taught Leonardo DiCaprio when he was a kid and River Phoenix and Joaquin Phoenix and Maggie Jillon Hall and Jake Gyllenhall and Jessica Beale and, you know, on and on. But the point being that I think that the kind of improv I came from was really playing the truth. So not going for the laughs, but finding the comments. comedy inside the truth. So that was why, as a kid, actually, I think I was thought of mostly as a dramatic actress. And then as I got older and then, you know, comedy happened for me. People were|||她教过孩子。她的名字叫黛安·希尔·哈丁（Diane Hill Harden）。她教过小时候的莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥、瑞凡·菲尼克斯、华金·菲尼克斯、玛吉·吉伦哈尔、杰克·吉伦哈尔、杰西卡·贝尔等等，等等。但重点是，我认为我所接受的即兴表演其实是“演绎真实”。所以不是为了追求笑料而去搞笑，而是在真实之中寻找喜剧效果。这就是为什么在我小时候，人们其实大都把我当作戏剧演员来看待。后来随着我长大，喜剧机缘落到了我头上。人们会觉得
like, oh, wow, she's really funny. But I think that's where the chemistry comes from, really. It literally is just that I say Steve could throw a ball. It could be a curve ball. And I would get so excited by that and catch it. And then he could throw a straight ball the next time or an underhanded ball the next time or an overhanded ball the next time. And I was just always like ready to catch those balls. And he was exactly the same way. So I think we had a lot of fun. I certainly did. I can't speak for Steve, but it felt like we both did. But I certainly had a lot of fun tossing those balls in different ways, even subtly all the time. And I think that does come from a comfort with the unknown, a comfort with improv. Well, to continue that metaphor, I like this metaphor of the idea of like pitchers and catchers
like, oh, wow, she's really funny. But I think that's where the chemistry comes from, really. It literally is just that I say Steve could throw a ball. It could be a curve ball. And I would get so excited by that and catch it. And then he could throw a straight ball the next time or an underhanded ball the next time or an overhanded ball the next time and I was just always like ready to catch those balls. And he was exactly the same way. So I think we had a lot of fun. I certainly did. I can't speak for Steve, but it felt like we both did. But I certainly had a lot of fun tossing those balls in different ways, even subtly all the time. And I think that does come from a comfort with the unknown, a comfort with improv. Well, to continue that metaphor, I like this metaphor of the idea of like pitchers and catchers|||，哦，哇，她真的很有趣。但我想化学反应正是来源于此。字面意思就是，比如史蒂夫可以投出一个球。那可能是一个曲线球。我会对此感到非常兴奋并接住它。然后他下次可以投一个直球，或者下一次投一个低手球，或者再下一次投一个高手球，而我总是随时准备接住那些球。他也是完全一样的。所以我认为我们玩得很开心。我当然是这样的。我不能代表史蒂夫，但感觉我们俩都很开心。但我确实从那些不断变换方式（哪怕是微妙的变化）抛接球的过程中得到了很多乐趣。我想这确实来自于对未知的游刃有余，以及对即兴表演的得心应手。好吧，延续这个比喻，我喜欢这种把即兴表演比作投手和捕手的想法
in improv and I sort of saw myself on the show as more of a catcher of other people's improv. But I think you have the, what makes Jan so fun is that you're both. I think Jan was a pitcher and a catcher because I would see it on set as well. Like you'd just toss it right back to him, you know, but you'd catch it just right too. So, thanks. What fun. Yeah, yeah, it is fun. And that's a really great observation about your character.
in improv and I sort of saw myself on the show as more of a catcher of other people's improv. But I think you have the, what makes Jan so fun is that you're both. I think Jan was a pitcher and a catcher because I would see it on set as well. Like you'd just toss it right back to him, you know, but you'd catch it just right too. So, thanks. What fun. Yeah, yeah, it is fun. And that's a really great observation about your character.|||，我在剧中其实更多地把自己看作是接住别人即兴表演的捕手。但我觉得你拥有……简之所以这么有趣，是因为你两者兼备。我认为简既是投手又是捕手，因为我也在片场见证过。比如你直接把球回传给他，你知道的，但你也能把球接得恰到好处。所以，谢谢。多有意思啊。是的，是的，这很有意思。对于你的角色，这是一个非常棒的观察。
I feel like you're totally right about that. that was what made her so special, too. Because she just was so always available for that from anybody, you know? Yeah. So great. So great. Yeah. I think the thing that really spoke to me and everything you said there was just playing the
I feel like you're totally right about that. that was what made her so special, too. Because she just was so always available for that from anybody, you know? Yeah. So great. So great. Yeah. I think the thing that really spoke to me and everything you said there was just playing the|||我觉得你完全说对了。这也是她如此特别的原因。因为她总是随时准备好接受任何人抛过来的梗，你知道的？是的。太棒了。太棒了。是的。我觉得你刚才说的一切真正触动我的地方，就是“演绎真实”。
truth. Because that's the highest brow of comedy, truly. It's not going for the joke. That's the cheapest way to go about getting a laugh is to go for the joke. But if you play the truth, it's so pure and real. And you did that so many times as Jane. Jan, I was watching you, oh my gosh, last night. There was a moment where Jan just finally decide she's going to get back together with Michael.
truth. Because that's the highest brow of comedy, truly. It's not going for the joke. That's the cheapest way to go about getting a laugh is to go for the joke. But if you play the truth, it's so pure and real. And you did that so many times as Jane. Jan, I was watching you, oh my gosh, last night. There was a moment where Jan just finally decide she's going to get back together with Michael.|||因为这才是最高雅的喜剧，真的。不是为了搞笑而搞笑。那是博取笑声最廉价的方式。但如果你演绎的是真实，它就会无比纯粹和真实。而你作为简，曾无数次做到这一点。简，天哪，昨晚我看着你。有一个瞬间是简终于决定要和迈克尔复合。
Even though he has sent the email to everyone, you know, Jan Tan everywhere, Jan everywhere. Like, it's gone so far. And as she's like, look, I don't know why my therapist told me just lean into this, but clearly I'm attracted to you. I don't know why. And Michael is trying to say back to you that he agrees, but he's so. excited and it comes out like, and I also henceforth do the thereby affirm this moment, like whatever, I'm paraphrasing it. But he says so many ridiculous things in a row saying yes. And then you have this moment where you just go, huh. So you, that what, I mean, those little moments
Even though he has sent the email to everyone, you know, Jan Tan everywhere, Jan everywhere. Like, it's gone so far. And as she's like, look, I don't know why my therapist told me just lean into this, but clearly I'm attracted to you. I don't know why. And Michael is trying to say back to you that he agrees, but he's so. excited and it comes out like, and I also henceforth do the thereby affirm this moment, like whatever, I'm paraphrasing it. But he says so many ridiculous things in a row saying yes. And then you have this moment where you just go, huh. So you, that what, I mean, those little moments|||尽管他已经给所有人发了邮件，你知道的，到处都是“简的晒黑照”，到处都是简。事情已经闹得不可开交了。而当她说，听着，我不知道为什么我的理疗师让我顺其自然，但很显然我被你吸引了。我不知道为什么。迈克尔试图回应你表示同意，但他太兴奋了，结果说出来的话变成了“因此我从今以后特此确认这一刻”，诸如此类的，我是在意译。但他连续说了很多荒谬的话来表示“我愿意”。然后你就有了一个瞬间，你只是发出了一声，哈。所以你，那个……我的意思是，那些微小的时刻
of you reacting to him are so truthful as Jan. Some of my favorites are your nonverbal. Yes. Yes. Yes. There's an elevator nonverbal that's literally, like, I'll do it with you when I see it. It's the one where you're like, Michael, you're a good looking guy, but I just this and you're annoying and I can't stand you. And you say all these insults. And it's just not going to happen between us. And then he says, you think I'm good looking.
of you reacting to him are so truthful as Jan. Some of my favorites are your nonverbal. Yes. Yes. Yes. There's an elevator nonverbal that's literally, like, I'll do it with you when I see it. It's the one where you're like, Michael, you're a good looking guy, but I just this and you're annoying and I can't stand you. And you say all these insults. And it's just not going to happen between us. And then he says, you think I'm good looking.|||你对他的反应作为简来说是如此真实。我最喜欢的其中一些是你那些非语言的表演。是的。是的。是的。有一个电梯里的非语言表演，字面意思就是，每次看到我都会跟你一起模仿。就是那个场景，你对他说，迈克尔，你是个长得不错的家伙，但我只是……而且你很烦人，我受不了你。你说了所有这些侮辱的话。我们之间是绝对不可能的。然后他说，你觉得我长得不错？
And you get in the elevator and you go, and then the door is shut. And it's just like, it's my favorite jam nonverbal. You have so many. And that one was the one where we got given the candy bag. And the scene started in Michael's office and we walked to the elevator. Continue having that argument. Getting the elevator and the doors closed. And that was that scene where they basically said, we're going to rewrite the scene.
And you get in the elevator and you go, and then the doors shut. And it's just like, it's my favorite jam nonverbal. You have so many. And that one was the one where we got given the candy bag. And the scene started in Michael's office and we walked to the elevator. Continue having that argument. Getting the elevator and the doors closed. And that was that scene where they basically said, we're going to rewrite the scene.|||然后你走进电梯，发出了“哼”的一声，接着电梯门就关上了。这简直了，这是我最喜欢的简的非语言表演。你这样的表演太多了。而那场戏正是我们拿到糖果袋的那场。场景从迈克尔的办公室开始，我们走向电梯。继续争吵。走进电梯，电梯门关上。就是那场戏，编剧基本上说：我们要重写这场戏。
We don't like it. Basically, we need you to hit this beat. You guys improvised. We're going to go rewrite it. We'll be back. Have fun. They left. But we went off.
We don't like it. Basically, we need you to hit this beat. You guys improvised. We're going to go rewrite it. We'll be back. Have fun. They left. But we went off.|||我们不喜欢这样。基本上，我们需要你们卡准这个节拍。你们先即兴发挥吧。我们要去重写了。我们一会儿回来。玩的开心。他们就走了。但我们开始自由发挥了。
And I do know that definitely that scene is, I would say, 90% improvised. Wow. They were like, just go play. We're going to try it. Because they weren't liking the way it was playing, the way it was written. And they were just like, you know, Greg was extraordinary that way. That was the first set I'd ever been on with that much collaboration with the writers and the actors. That was just an extraordinary eye-opening, like, what?
And I do know that definitely that scene is, I would say, 90% improvised. Wow. They were like, just go play. We're going to try it. Because they weren't liking the way it was playing, the way it was written. And they were just like, you know, Greg was extraordinary that way. That was the first set I'd ever been on with that much collaboration with the writers and the actors. That was just an extraordinary eye-opening, like, what?|||而且我很清楚，那场戏绝对有百分之九十是即兴发挥的。哇。他们当时说，尽管去演吧。我们要试试看。因为他们不喜欢当时那种演法、那种剧本的写法。他们就觉得，你知道的，格雷格在这方面真是非同寻常。那是我去过的第一个编剧和演员合作如此紧密的剧组。这简直是一次非同寻常、让人大开眼界的体验，心想：什么？
And even what you said, Angela, Greg was extraordinary at that in terms of weaving in the truthful things. So that there are things about Jan that are very much Malora. Like I've often said, you know, I had Greg and Paul Fiege and his wife and Greg and Suzanne over for dinner one night. And I have a huge painting of myself. This was at an older house that we had that a friend of mine had painted that was the cover of my second album called Purr. And it was basically a nod to Gil Elvgren, who was the first pin-up painter before they could take photographs of women like that. There were painters that would paint women that were just a little cheeky where they'd be leaning over and picking up a garden hose and their skirt would be flying up and they'd be going
And even what you said, Angela, Greg was extraordinary at that in terms of weaving in the truthful things. So that there are things about Jan that are very much Malora. Like I've often said, you know, I had Greg and Paul Fiege and his wife and Greg and Suzanne over for dinner one night. And I have a huge painting of myself. This was at an older house that we had that a friend of mine had painted that was the cover of my second album called Purr. And it was basically a nod to Gil Elvgren, who was the first pin-up painter before they could take photographs of women like that. There were painters that would paint women that were just a little cheeky where they'd be leaning over and picking up a garden hose and their skirt would be flying up and they'd be going|||而且正如你所说的那样，安吉拉，格雷格在将真实的事情融入其中方面简直绝了。所以简身上有些特质非常像梅洛拉。就像我经常说的那样，你知道的，有一天晚上我请了格雷格、保罗·费格（Paul Feig）夫妇以及格雷格和苏珊（Suzanne）来家里吃晚饭。我有一幅巨大的自画像。那是在我们以前的老房子里，我的一位朋友画的，那是我第二张专辑《Purr》的封面。这基本上是在向吉尔·埃尔格伦（Gil Elvgren）致敬，他是早期拍摄女性照片之前的第一代海报女郎画师。当时的画师会画一些略带俏皮的女性，比如她们弯腰捡起花园水管，裙子随风飘起，然后她们会露出
oh and they'd have these cute little ruffly you know panties on and it was sort of a nod to that and it was you know my record was called purr and it was very kind of 50s 40s inspired music and so I had this painting over our couch in this very pretty but small living room that we had with hand-painted ceilings and I remember when they came in and I remember Greg noticing and I remember saying you know I often think sometimes people might come in my house and think that I think that's serious because I'm like sitting in this very provocative pose and I've got all these kittens all around me and, you know, my leg is out and my boobs are all pushed up and I'm like, you know, very smiley. And I said, but, you know, like, it's a joke. You know, it's a joke that goes with the music. It's perfectly for my record. But sometimes I think people might think that like, oh, wow, she really thinks that she's all that. I mean, I am all that, but, you know, that was a character. I was playing for the music. Anyway, so that was. the war hall of Jan came from. And the candle thing came because, again, when I came for dinner,
oh and they'd have these cute little ruffly you know panties on and it was sort of a nod to that and it was you know, my record was called purr and it was very kind of 50s 40s inspired music and so I had this painting over our couch in this very pretty but small living room that we had with hand-painted ceilings and I remember when they came in and I remember Greg noticing and I remember saying, you know, I often think sometimes people might come in my house and think that I think that's serious because I'm like sitting in this very provocative pose and I've got all these kittens all around me and, you know, my leg is out and my boobs are all pushed up and I'm like, you know, very smiley. And I said, but, you know, like, it's a joke. You know, it's a joke that goes with the music. It's perfectly for my record. But sometimes I think people might think that like, oh, wow, she really thinks that she's all that. I mean, I am all that, but, you know, that was a character. I was playing for the music. Anyway, so that was. the war hall of Jan came from. And the candle thing came because, again, when I came for dinner,|||哦的表情，身上穿着那种可爱的小花边内裤，这算是对那种风格的一种致敬。而且你知道的，我的唱片名叫《Purr》，那是受40、50年代风格启发而创作的音乐。所以我在我们那间有着手绘天花板的、非常漂亮但很小的客厅的沙发上方挂了这幅画。我记得他们进来的时候，我记得格雷格注意到了。我还记得我说过，你知道的，我经常觉得有时候人们来到我家，可能会以为我觉得那是件很严肃的事，因为我以一种非常挑逗的姿态坐着，周围全是小猫，你知道的，我一条腿伸出来，胸部被托得高高的，脸上挂着微笑。我说，但是，你知道的，这只是个玩笑。你知道的，这是配合音乐的一个玩笑。它完全是为了我的唱片服务的。但有时我想人们可能会觉得，哦，哇，她真的觉得自己了不起。我是说，我确实很了不起，但你知道的，那是个角色。我是为了音乐在扮演那个角色。总之，简的波普艺术画就是这么来的。至于蜡烛的设定，是因为，还是那句话，当我来吃晚饭时，
it was just like I had the whole house lit up with candles. I mean, I'm a candle fiend. I just am, especially back then. But I really literally would just light the whole house with candles. And I just thought it was so romantic and so sexy and so beautiful and such a beautiful environment. And I just think that he was like, you know, he was just taking mental notes.
it was just like I had the whole house lit up with candles. I mean, I'm a candle fiend. I just am, especially back then. But I really literally would just light the whole house with candles. And I just thought it was so romantic and so sexy and so beautiful and such a beautiful environment. And I just think that he was like, you know, he was just taking mental notes.|||整个房子里都点满了蜡烛。我是说，我是个蜡烛狂魔。我就是这样，特别是在那个时候。我真的会字面意义上把整个房子的蜡烛都点亮。我只是觉得这太浪漫、太性感、太美了，环境是如此优美。我想他当时就在心里默默记下了这些细节。
And he gave Jan the camera. Candle business because, you know, Belora loves candles. I'm so, anyway, those are funny things. Yeah. Yeah. No, I love all of that. And I love just the through lines that they would pull back over and over again. I watched this morning when Dwight and Pam, they think they're making a sale to some
And he gave Jan the camera. Candle business because, you know, Belora loves candles. I'm so, anyway, those are funny things. Yeah. Yeah. No, I love all of that. And I love just the through lines that they would pull back over and over again. I watched this morning when Dwight and Pam, they think they're making a sale to some|||于是他给了简一个……蜡烛生意，因为，你知道的，梅洛拉喜欢蜡烛。我真是，总之，这些都是有趣的事情。对的。对的。不，我太喜欢这些了。而且我特别喜欢他们一遍又一遍回收利用的那些故事主线。我今天早上看了一集，当时德怀特和潘以为他们要把东西卖给某个
unknown person, but it's actually Jan at her new job. Oh, my God. Once again, that was in the last season. That's right. But all of those paintings of Jan are back on the wall in her office. Then there's one of her skydiving. It's just a huge one of herself. Oh, yeah.
unknown person, but it's actually Jan at her new job. Oh, my God. Once again, that was in the last season. That's right. But all of those paintings of Jan are back on the wall in her office. Then there's one of her skydiving. It's just a huge one of herself. Oh, yeah.|||不知名的人，但实际上那是换了新工作的简。哦，天哪。又来了，那是最后一季里的事。没毛病。但简的所有那些画又回到了她办公室的墙上。然后还有一张她高空跳伞的照片。那是一张她自己的巨幅照片。哦，对。
I really wondered if you got to keep any of that, if you have any of those. You know what? I would love the skydiving one. No, I did get given the Jan Warhol. I have that rolled up somewhere. And then I have the spark parking space reserved for Jan Levinson, Michael Scott's girlfriend. I have that one from the prop guys. Yeah.
I really wondered if you got to keep any of that, if you have any of those. You know what? I would love the skydiving one. No, I did get given the Jan Warhol. I have that rolled up somewhere. And then I have the spark parking space reserved for Jan Levinson, Michael Scott's girlfriend. I have that one from the prop guys. Yeah.|||我很想知道你有没有留着其中的哪张，你有没有这些东西。你知道吗？我挺想要那张跳伞的。不，我的确得到了那幅“简版安迪·沃霍尔画”。我把它卷起来收在某个地方了。然后我还有一个保留车位，上面写着“简·莱文森，迈克尔·斯科特的女友专用车位”。那是道具组给我的。是的。
Oh, I love that. Yeah, that's pretty fun. And I have it in my house up, upside, up high, outside my door. And so sometimes, like work people or like people delivering packages, sometimes because it's up above your eye level, you don't necessarily see it. But sometimes they'll see it. And if they see it, they are so excited. Because then they put that with my face and they're just like, whee! Oh my God, I'm delivering to Jan.
Oh, I love that. Yeah, that's pretty fun. And I have it in my house up, upside, up high, outside my door. And so sometimes, like work people or like people delivering packages, sometimes because it's up above your eye level, you don't necessarily see it. But sometimes they'll see it. And if they see it, they are so excited. Because then they put that with my face and they're just like, whee! Oh my God, I'm delivering to Jan.|||哦，我太喜欢了。对，这挺有意思的。我把它挂在我家门外高高的墙上。所以有时候，比如工作人员或者送快递的人，因为挂在视线水平以上，他们不一定能注意到。但有时他们会看到。如果他们看到了，就会超级兴奋。因为他们会把那个标志和我的脸联系起来，然后就会发出“哇”的惊呼！天哪，我在给简送快递。
They can't believe it. They're so excited. All right. We have a question from Vicki G in Argentina. Yeah. And I actually have strong feelings about this. So I'm curious to know your answer. Okay. All right. Vicky would like to know, did Jan ever really love Michael or did she just need him?
They can't believe it. They're so excited. All right. We have a question from Vicki G in Argentina. Yeah. And I actually have strong feelings about this. So I'm curious to know your answer. Okay. All right. Vicky would like to know, did Jan ever really love Michael or did she just need him?|||他们简直不敢相信。他们太兴奋了。好了。我们有一个来自阿根廷的维姬·G.（Vicki G.）的问题。是的。我其实对此有着强烈的感受。所以我很好奇你的答案。好的。好的。维姬想知道，简曾经真的爱过迈克尔吗？还是她只是需要他？
And also, a lot of people wrote in asking if Hunter is really the father of Jan's baby because they think maybe Jan was pregnant at the dinner party and they'd like to know your thoughts. Wow. I love how deeply these people think into the storyline. That's really great. I think Jan did love Michael as much as she could. I just think she was quite broken around love. You know, she had this other husband, the Gould guy, and I think that was probably the picture perfect marriage. That's probably what it looked like. And that's what she chose thinking that was what she should have.
And also, a lot of people wrote in asking if Hunter is really the father of Jan's baby because they think maybe Jan was pregnant at the dinner party and they'd like to know your thoughts. Wow. I love how deeply these people think into the storyline. That's really great. I think Jan did love Michael as much as she could. I just think she was quite broken around love. You know, she had this other husband, the Gould guy, and I think that was probably the picture perfect marriage. That's probably what it looked like. And that's what she chose thinking that was what she should have.|||还有，许多人写信问亨特是不是简孩子的亲生父亲，因为他们觉得简可能在晚宴时就已经怀孕了，他们想听听你的想法。哇。我很喜欢这些观众对剧情进行如此深入的思考。这真的很棒。我觉得简尽她所能地去爱迈克尔了。我只是觉得她在爱情方面受过很重的伤。你知道的，她之前有过另一个丈夫，那个叫戈德的家伙，我想那可能是一段完美的婚姻。看起来大概就是那样。她选择了那个，以为那是她应该拥有的生活。
He had the right bank account. He had the right job. He had the right clothes. They had the right house. And I think that when she left that, the thing. I always was playing because I remember also again back to Greg. I mean, Greg and I did a lot of talking about Jan and a lot of thinking. And there was a lot of like his wheels turning and I could see that. And I think very early on, he said to me something like, we're having a little trouble in the
He had the right bank account. He had the right job. He had the right clothes. They had the right house. And I think that when she left that, the thing. I always was playing because I remember also again back to Greg. I mean, Greg and I did a lot of talking about Jan and a lot of thinking. And there was a lot of like his wheels turning and I could see that. And I think very early on, he said to me something like, we're having a little trouble in the|||他有合适的银行账户。他有合适的工作。他有合适的衣服。他们有合适的房子。而我认为当她离开这一切时……我一直在揣摩，因为我还记得回到格雷格的话题上。我是说，我和格雷格就简这个角色进行过很多次长谈和思考。他的脑子里一直在高速运转，我能看得出来。我觉得很早以前，他对我说过类似这样的话：我们在
writer's room reconciling with this idea that Jan would ever be with Michael. And I remember this was a real conversation with the writers. And I remember saying, I think that it really works. And it wasn't just because I wanted to stay on the show. I did. But it wasn't really that. It was that I could feel that chemistry that Steve and Malora had. But it was really, it was Jan and Michael. And it was like, there was something that was a little broken about Jan that Michael could fill because he was very childlike, actually. He was very childlike, even in his, like, his delusional, you know, thinking everything was amazing. And I think probably at the beginning of the relationship, he was like that with her. He was like, you know, how could I get so lucky to have this beautiful, talented, successful woman, strong, powerful woman that can dominate him, which is what he really loved. I think she was quite dominant of him. And I think that he was just like a puppy dog, just like, Oh my God. Like he would show up at the door like a dog with his tail wagging, you know, with his tongue
writer's room reconciling with this idea that Jan would ever be with Michael. And I remember this was a real conversation with the writers. And I remember saying, I think that it really works. And it wasn't just because I wanted to stay on the show. I did. But it wasn't really that. It was that I could feel that chemistry that Steve and Malora had. But it was really, it was Jan and Michael. And it was like, there was something that was a little broken about Jan that Michael could fill because he was very childlike, actually. He was very childlike, even in his, like, his delusional, you know, thinking everything was amazing. And I think probably at the beginning of the relationship, he was like that with her. He was like, you know, how could I get so lucky to have this beautiful, talented, successful woman, strong, powerful woman that can dominate him, which is what he really loved. I think she was quite dominant of him. And I think that he was just like a puppy dog, just like, Oh my God. Like he would show up at the door like a dog with his tail wagging, you know, with his tongue|||编剧室里很难调和这样一个设定——简怎么可能会和迈克尔在一起。我记得这是我和编剧之间的一次真实对话。我记得当时我说，我觉得这真的行得通。这不仅仅是因为我想留在剧中（虽然我确实想）。但真的不只是那样。是我能感受到史蒂夫和梅洛拉之间的那种化学反应。但实际上，那是简和迈克尔之间的反应。就像简身上有些破碎的地方可以由迈克尔来填补，因为他非常像个孩子，真的。他非常像个孩子，哪怕是在他那些妄想中——你知道的，觉得一切都棒极了。我想可能在恋情刚开始的时候，他对她就是那样的。他当时就像是，你知道的，我怎么能这么幸运，能拥有这样一个美丽、有才华、成功、坚强、有力量、能主导他的女性——这正是他真正热爱的。我觉得她在很大程度上主导了他。而且我觉得他就像一只小狗一样，简直是“天哪”。就像他会像一只摇着尾巴的狗一样出现在门口，你知道的，伸着舌头
out. Like, what are we going to do today? And she would make the plans. And so when they say, like, was she really in love with him? I mean, you know, was it like deep philosophical, existential love? I don't know. But for those two people, those two characters, I think they loved each other as much as those two people could love another human being.
out. Like, what are we going to do today? And she would make the plans. And so when they say, like, was she really in love with him? I mean, you know, was it like deep philosophical, existential love? I don't know. But for those two people, those two characters, I think they loved each other as much as those two people could love another human being.|||。就像在问：我们今天要做什么？而她会做好计划。所以当他们问起，比如说，她真的爱他吗？我是说，你知道的，那是那种深奥的哲学层面的、存在主义的爱吗？我不知道。但对于那两个人、那两个角色来说，我认为他们彼此相爱的程度，已经达到了那两个人所能去爱另一个人类的极限。
So I would say fully yes for that. And I want to know your strong opinions on that, Jenna. Do you think they were? Yes. Okay. 100%. For all the reasons that you said, and I love what you're saying about Greg,
So I would say fully yes for that. And I want to know your strong opinions on that, Jenna. Do you think they were? Yes. Okay. 100%. For all the reasons that you said, and I love what you're saying about Greg,|||所以我完全会对此投赞成票。珍娜，我想知道你对此有什么强烈的看法。你觉得他们是真的相爱吗？是的。好的。百分之百。为了你说的所有那些理由，而且我太喜欢你刚才对格雷格的评价了，
you know, it's funny if Jan and Michael are together, but Greg wanted to make sure it was also truthful and real that they were together. And so he was saying, we're trying to figure out, like, what's the truth of these two characters being together? We know what's funny about it. Right, right. And so, but I think it is what you're saying, which is like there was a time and place in these two.
you know, it's funny if Jan and Michael are together, but Greg wanted to make sure it was also truthful and real that they were together. And so he was saying, we're trying to figure out, like, what's the truth of these two characters being together? We know what's funny about it. Right, right. And so, but I think it is what you're saying, which is like there was a time and place in these two.|||你知道的，简和迈克尔在一起很有趣，但格雷格希望确保他们在一起的过程同样是真实可信的。所以他说过，我们正在努力找出这两名角色在一起的真实动机是什么？我们知道这有什么搞笑的。对的，对的。所以，但我认为这就是你所说的，就像在这两个人的生命中，曾有过一个时间和地点，
people's lives where they were just perfect for one another. And they did need each other. That was one of Vicki's questions. Was it just a need-based relationship? But no, I think it went beyond that. I think there was some healing that happened. Yeah, I do too. You know. And play. I think they had a lot playfulness in the fact that her dominance and his sort of passiveness, where he has to show up at work and be the guy who's in charge and be the boss. Where he's really not suited to be a boss, right? But he is. He's the boss of Dundra Mifflin. It's hilarious. And then she's the bigger boss and she gets to boss him around. And I think that was really hot for him. That was what I always got. That was hot for him and hot for her because I think Gould was much more dominant. And I think that wasn't comfortable for her. I always used to say too that Jan sort of tossed out her femininity to kind of climb that corporate ladder that she felt she had to sort of be masculine. She had to be kind of one of the guys. And I think that Michael re-ignited that feminine part of her that was dominant but playful. And I think he probably could get her to soften in their private moments, in their intimate moments.
people's lives where they were just perfect for one another. And they did need each other. That was one of Vicki's questions. Was it just a need-based relationship? But no, I think it went beyond that. I think there was some healing that happened. Yeah, I do too. You know. And play. I think they had a lot playfulness in the fact that her dominance and his sort of passiveness, where he has to show up at work and be the guy who's in charge and be the boss. Where he's really not suited to be a boss, right? But he is. He's the boss of Dundra Mifflin. It's hilarious. And then she's the bigger boss and she gets to boss him around. And I think that was really hot for him. That was what I always got. That was hot for him and hot for her because I think Gould was much more dominant. And I think that wasn't comfortable for her. I always used to say too that Jan sort of tossed out her femininity to kind of climb that corporate ladder that she felt she had to sort of be masculine. She had to be kind of one of the guys. And I think that Michael re-ignited that feminine part of her that was dominant but playful. And I think he probably could get her to soften in their private moments, in their intimate moments.|||他们简直是天作之合。而且他们确实需要彼此。那是维姬的问题之一。这只是一种基于需求的恋爱关系吗？但我觉得不仅如此。我觉得其中发生了一些疗愈。是的，我也这么觉得。你知道的。还有情趣。我觉得他们之间有很多情趣，因为她的强势和他的那种被动——他在工作场所必须表现得像是掌权的人、当老板的人。尽管他其实根本不适合当老板，对吧？但他确实是。他是邓德·米夫林的老板。这太滑稽了。然后她是更大的老板，她可以对颐指气使。我觉得这对他来说非常有吸引力。这是我一直以来的感受。这对他们俩来说都很有吸引力，因为我觉得戈德要强势得多。而且我觉得这让她感到不舒服。我过去也经常说，简为了往上爬，几乎抛弃了自己的女性特质，她觉得自己必须表现得男性化一点。她必须融入男人们的圈子。而我认为迈克尔重新点燃了她身上那种主导却又带点俏皮的女性特质。我觉得在他们的私密时刻、亲密时刻，他很可能能让她变得温柔下来。
I always imagine that they had great sex and some really sweet, tender moments too, where I think they did have that kind of healing, you know, flavor that I think you're talking about there. Yeah, I believe they snuggled on the couch and watched movies. I do, I do, I do. I do, I think they stungled on the couch and watched movies. I think they filmed themselves having sex. I think they did all of those things. We know they did that. Yes, we know they did that.
I always imagine that they had great sex and some really sweet, tender moments too, where I think they did have that kind of healing, you know, flavor that I think you're talking about there. Yeah, I believe they snuggled on the couch and watched movies. I do, I do, I do. I do, I think they stungled on the couch and watched movies. I think they filmed themselves having sex. I think they did all of those things. We know they did that. Yes, we know they did that.|||我一直想象他们有着很棒的性爱，也有一些非常甜蜜、温柔的时刻，我觉得他们在那些时刻确实拥有了你所说的那种疗愈的氛围。是的，我相信他们会依偎在沙发上一起看电影。真的，真的，真的。真的，我觉得他们会依偎在沙发上一起看电影。我觉得他们会把做爱过程拍下来。我觉得他们把这些事都做了。我们知道他们做过。是的，我们知道他们做过。
We know they did that. But also they have this super sweet scene where Michael is bankrupt, basically. Jan is spending his money, but he also hasn't been good with his money. And they're sitting in the train, the empty train cart. That's such a sweet scene. Jan says, like, look, you know, after I lost my job, like my friends aren't talking to me. These people have banned me. No one, you know, whatever, my family under legal, like, restraints can talk to me.
We know they did that. But also they have this super sweet scene where Michael is bankrupt, basically. Jan is spending his money, but he also hasn't been good with his money. And they're sitting in the train, the empty train cart. That's such a sweet scene. Jan says, like, look, you know, after I lost my job, like my friends aren't talking to me. These people have banned me. No one, you know, whatever, my family under legal, like, restraints can talk to me.|||我们知道他们做过。但他们还有一个超级甜蜜的场景，当时迈克尔基本上破产了。简在花他的钱，但他自己其实也不擅长理财。他们坐在火车上，空荡荡的车厢里。那真是一个非常甜蜜的场景。简说，看吧，你知道的，在我失业之后，我的朋友们都不理我了。这些人把我拉黑了。没有谁，你知道的，管他呢，我的家人在法律限制下才能跟我说话。
And then she's like, but you're always here for me. Yeah. And I think, you know, there was some real truth to that. Michael was always there for Jan. Yeah, he really was. He was. And so I think that was healing for Jan. Yeah, I didn't give up on her.
And then she's like, but you're always here for me. Yeah. And I think, you know, there was some real truth to that. Michael was always there for Jan. Yeah, he really was. He was. And so I think that was healing for Jan. Yeah, I didn't give up on her.|||然后她说，但你一直都在我身边。是的。我想，这里面确实有着某种真实的成分。迈克尔一直陪在简身边。是的，他真的是。他确实是。所以我觉得这对简来说是一种疗愈。是的，他没有放弃她。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Aw, that's sweet. But what about the baby? Yes, what about the baby? Was Astrid Kevin Malone's sperm donor baby? or was Astrid Hunter's baby? I think, yeah, exactly.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Aw, that's sweet. But what about the baby? Yes, what about the baby? Was Astrid Kevin Malone's sperm donor baby? or was Astrid Hunter's baby? I think, yeah, exactly.|||对，完全正确。是的。啊，真温馨。但孩子呢？对，孩子呢？阿斯特丽德（Astrid）是凯文·马龙（Kevin Malone）捐精生下的孩子吗？还是阿斯特丽德是亨特的孩子的？我想，是的，完全正确。
She wasn't Michael's baby because of the vasectomy and the double condoms that she insisted that he wears. So I think we're pretty sure it's not Michael's. Definitely was not Michaels. Yeah, I mean, we had played it that it was that she had gotten a sperm donor. Kevin, no way.
She wasn't Michael's baby because of the vasectomy and the double condoms that she insisted that he wears. So I think we're pretty sure it's not Michael's. Definitely was not Michaels. Yeah, I mean, we had played it that it was that she had gotten a sperm donor. Kevin, no way.|||这绝对不是迈克尔的孩子，因为他做过输精管切除手术，而且她坚持让他戴双层安全套。所以我想我们完全可以确定这不是迈克尔的。绝对不是迈克尔的。是的，我是说，我们在剧中演的就是她去找了精子捐献者。凯文？绝不可能。
That would just be him, you know, being Kevin. But no, I don't think it would have been hunters. No. I don't think it would have been hunters either. I think that would be nice because I'm sure they had sex. But I don't think it was hunters. I think it was a sperm donor. Like I think she literally went and got an anonymous, you know, sperm donors, sperm. And that would be the way Jan would do it. She would be very meticulous and very across all the T's and dot all the eyes. I bet she didn't get an open one either. I bet she didn't get the one where you can find your father. Yeah, she locked it up. Because I think she really kind of wanted to go back to Michael, too. I think some part of her was like he could help me raise this kid. There's probably some part of her that had that fantasy, which was never going to be a reality. Okay, I agree.
That would just be him, you know, being Kevin. But no, I don't think it would have been hunters. No. I don't think it would have been hunters either. I think that would be nice because I'm sure they had sex. But I don't think it was hunters. I think it was a sperm donor. Like I think she literally went and got an anonymous, you know, sperm donors, sperm. And that would be the way Jan would do it. She would be very meticulous and very across all the T's and dot all the eyes. I bet she didn't get an open one either. I bet she didn't get the one where you can find your father. Yeah, she locked it up. Because I think she really kind of wanted to go back to Michael, too. I think some part of her was like he could help me raise this kid. There's probably some part of her that had that fantasy, which was never going to be a reality. Okay, I agree.|||那只能说明他就是凯文嘛。但我觉得不可能是亨特的。不。我也觉得不可能是亨特的。我觉得如果是那样也挺好，因为我确信他们发生过性关系。但我觉得那不是亨特的。我觉得那是精子捐献者的。就像我觉得她字面意义上去找了一个匿名的、你知道的，精子捐献者的精子。这才是简的做事风格。她会非常一丝不苟，把所有细节都处理得滴水不漏。我敢打赌她甚至没有选那种“开放式”的捐献者。我敢打赌她没有选那种将来能找到亲生父亲的。对，她把这条路锁死了。因为我觉得她其实也有点想回到迈克尔身边。我觉得她内心深处某一部分觉得他可以帮我养大这个孩子。她内心深处可能曾有过那种幻想，虽然那永远不会变成现实。好吧，我同意。
Because like I said, I'm rewatching the show. We just watched a fun run last night. And that's the one where Kevin finds Jan at the grocery store and she's pregnant and he calls Michael. And then Michael comes down. And you have this great conversation. It is so heartbreaking. and it, oh, it just punched me in the gut, where Michael is like, is it mine? And she's like, no. And he's like, but it has to be mine because you clearly got pregnant when we were together
Because like I said, I'm rewatching the show. We just watched a fun run last night. And that's the one where Kevin finds Jan at the grocery store and she's pregnant and he calls Michael. And then Michael comes down. And you have this great conversation. It is so heartbreaking. and it, oh, it just punched me in the gut, where Michael is like, is it mine? And she's like, no. And he's like, but it has to be mine because you clearly got pregnant when we were together|||因为就像我说的，我在重看这部剧。我们昨晚刚看了《趣味长跑》那一集。就是凯文在杂货店遇到怀孕的简的那集，他给迈克尔打了电话。然后迈克尔赶了过去。你们有了一段精彩的对话。那段对话太让人心碎了，天哪，简直重重地捶了我的心窝一下。迈克尔问：是我的吗？而她说：不是。他说：但这一定我的，因为很明显我们在一起的时候你怀孕了
and you say, I did. And then he says, I can't believe you cheated on me when I specifically asked you not to. That's such a great line. And it's such a great line. And you're like, I didn't cheat on you. And he's just like, I can't figure this out. And that's when you tell him, I went to a sperm bank, Michael. Yeah. And he says, you went to a sperm bank when you were with me? Right. It's so hurtful.
and you say, I did. And then he says, I can't believe you cheated on me when I specifically asked you not to. That's such a great line. And it's such a great line. And you're like, I didn't cheat on you. And he's just like, I can't figure this out. And that's when you tell him, I went to a sperm bank, Michael. Yeah. And he says, you went to a sperm bank when you were with me? Right. It's so hurtful.|||而你说：我是怀过孕。然后他说：我简直不敢相信你在我明确要求你不要这样做的情况下还出轨。这台词写得太棒了。这台词真的太棒了。而你说：我没有出轨。而他只是说：我搞不懂这到底是为什么。就在那时你告诉他：我去了精子库，迈克尔。是的。然后他说：你在跟我在一起的时候去过精子库？对。这太伤人了。
It's so painful. But then there's this great talking head where Jan explains like, yeah, yeah. Listen, if I were younger, maybe I give Michael a shot. But I can't take it. I needed a great sperm from a great, like everything you're saying. A young, fast. A fantastic. Yes.
It's so painful. But then there's this great talking head where Jan explains like, yeah, yeah. Listen, if I were younger, maybe I give Michael a shot. But I can't take it. I needed a great sperm from a great, like everything you're saying. A young, fast. A fantastic. Yes.|||这太痛苦了。但接下来有一个非常棒的单人采访镜头，简在里面解释说：行了，行了。听着，如果我再年轻点，也许我会给迈克尔一次机会。但我现在不能冒这个险。我需要优秀的精子来自一个优秀的——就像你刚才说的一切。年轻的、充满活力的。棒极了。是的。
Yeah. No, she was. With great DNA. Yes. This was planning. She was smart. She was not messing around. And she knew this was her last shot to have a kid.
Yeah. No, she was. With great DNA. Yes. This was planning. She was smart. She was not messing around. And she knew this was her last shot to have a kid.|||对。没错，她是这样的。拥有优秀的DNA。是的。这是有计划的。她很聪明。她可不是在瞎胡闹。她知道这是她生孩子的最后机会。
Like, I'm going to do it. I'm going to do it now. Yes. Oh my gosh. That scene is amazing. Yeah. Well, I have a question for you from Amber V in New Hampshire. Amber says, what was Malora's favorite Jan storyline?
Like, I'm going to do it. I'm going to do it now. Yes. Oh my gosh. That scene is amazing. Yeah. Well, I have a question for you from Amber V in New Hampshire. Amber says, what was Malora's favorite Jan storyline?|||就像是，我要做这件事。我现在就要做。是的。哦，天哪。那场戏太绝了。是的。好吧，新罕布什尔州的安伯·V.（Amber V.）有一个问题想问你。安伯问：梅洛拉最喜欢的简的故事线是什么？
And Rachel O from South Dakota said, is there a storyline you wish would have played out differently or maybe have gotten more depth. Hmm. I mean, nobody can really look at Jan and not see the dinner party storyline being sort of brilliant as far as just what happened in that evening, the invitation of people over, and all of these characters crashing together in a way that we just didn't see. I mean, most of my scenes, all of my scenes really were with Steve.
And Rachel O from South Dakota said, is there a storyline you wish would have played out differently or maybe have gotten more depth. Hmm. I mean, nobody can really look at Jan and not see the dinner party storyline being sort of brilliant as far as just what happened in that evening, the invitation of people over, and all of these characters crashing together in a way that we just didn't see. I mean, most of my scenes, all of my scenes really were with Steve.|||南达科他州的雷切尔·O.（Rachel O.）问：有没有哪条故事线你希望当时的走向能有所不同，或者能够挖掘得更深一些？嗯。我是说，任何人回顾简的故事，都无法忽视《晚宴》那一集的故事线简直堪称辉煌——单就那天晚上发生的事情而言，邀请大家来做客，所有这些角色以一种我们从未见过的独特方式碰撞在一起。我是说，我的大部分戏份，实际上我所有的戏份都是和史蒂夫一起演的。
And sometimes other characters would pop in and out. But nothing significant with Jan was with anyone. but Steve, except in the dinner party. Oh, and then also that last season nine, that one was also cool because that was with you and was it you and who? Rain. Oh, it was you and Rain. That's right.
And sometimes other characters would pop in and out. But nothing significant with Jan was with anyone. but Steve, except in the dinner party. Oh, and then also that last season nine, that one was also cool because that was with you and was it you and who? Rain. Oh, it was you and Rain. That's right.|||有时其他角色会偶尔出场。但简的重头戏从来没有跟史蒂夫以外的任何人演过，除了《晚宴》那一集。哦，还有最后一季第九季的那场戏也很酷，因为那是你和……是你和谁来着？雷恩（Rainn）。哦，是你和雷恩。对的。
But mostly you, right. It was mostly the two of us. Yeah, that's right. You show me a slideshow. That's right. Yes, I remember that. Of Astrid. And I sing that song.
But mostly you, right. It was mostly the two of us. Yeah, that's right. You show me a slideshow. That's right. Yes, I remember that. Of Astrid. And I sing that song.|||但主要是你，对吧。主要就是我们俩。对的，没错。你给我看了一个幻灯片。没错。是的，我记得。是关于阿斯特丽德的。而我唱了那首歌。
I'm singing the song on the slideshow. And I'm nowling the words to it. That's right. Ridiculous. Absolutely ridiculous. And the song is completely everybody. That was completely improvised. Oh my gosh.
I'm singing the song on the slideshow. And I'm nowling the words to it. That's right. Ridiculous. Absolutely ridiculous. And the song is completely everybody. That was completely improvised. Oh my gosh.|||我在幻灯片播放时唱了那首歌。我还在哼着歌词。没错。太荒谬了。简直荒谬透顶。而且这首歌完全是……那是完全即兴发挥的。哦，天哪。
Are you kidding? Yeah, they just gave me the lyrics and they were like, and they know I'm a songwriter and a singer. They were just like, yeah, just, I don't know, sing it. And so I came up with a whole melody. That is so ridiculous. The melody itself, as a melodicist and a lyricist, I'm telling you, the melody of that is so ridiculous. I've had people before on Cameo asked me to sing that song, and I have to go back to YouTube and watch it. And I go, this is the weirdest melody.
Are you kidding? Yeah, they just gave me the lyrics and they were like, and they know I'm a songwriter and a singer. They were just like, yeah, just, I don't know, sing it. And so I came up with a whole melody. That is so ridiculous. The melody itself, as a melodicist and a lyricist, I'm telling you, the melody of that is so ridiculous. I've had people before on Cameo asked me to sing that song, and I have to go back to YouTube and watch it. And I go, this is the weirdest melody.|||你在开玩笑吗？是的，他们只是把歌词交给我，然后他们就说——而且他们知道我是个词曲创作者和歌手——他们当时就说，行吧，就随便……唱一下。于是我现场编出了一整段旋律。这太荒谬了。作为一名旋律创作者和词作家，我告诉你，那段旋律简直荒谬至极。以前在Cameo上曾有人让我唱那首歌，我还得特意回YouTube上去看一遍。然后我心想：这绝对是最诡异的旋律。
It's just like, I have to figure it. Oh my gosh. And I know I just came up with it on the spot. No, it's so bonkers. I was watching it this morning. And I don't know how, first of all, you guys got through that without laughing. I don't know how you did it. It was so crazy. Wait, I want to play it. Can I play it? Can I play it? You can play it. Or is it weird? You're here. No, you can play it. No, I'll play it. Oh, I don't know. Maybe. If I listen to it once, I could probably sing alone. I remember having to sit there and it's such a great scene because Pam's trying to get this sale. You know, she's trying to get you as a client.
It's just like, I have to figure it. Oh my gosh. And I know I just came up with it on the spot. No, it's so bonkers. I was watching it this morning. And I don't know how, first of all, you guys got through that without laughing. I don't know how you did it. It was so crazy. Wait, I want to play it. Can I play it? Can I play it? You can play it. Or is it weird? You're here. No, you can play it. No, I'll play it. Oh, I don't know. Maybe. If I listen to it once, I could probably sing alone. I remember having to sit there and it's such a great scene because Pam's trying to get this sale. You know, she's trying to get you as a client.|||就像是，我必须把它琢磨出来。哦，天哪。而且我知道那是我是现场即兴发挥的。不，这太疯狂了。我今天早上还在看。首先我不知道你们当时是怎么忍住不笑把那场戏拍完的。我不知道你们是怎么做到的。太疯狂了。等等，我想放一下。我能放吗？我能放吗？你可以放。或者这样很奇怪吗？你就在这。不，你可以放。不，我来放。哦，我不知道。也许吧。如果我听一遍，我大概就能独自唱出来了。我记得当时我不得不坐在那里，那真是一场极棒的戏，因为潘正试图促成这笔生意。你知道的，她正试图争取你成为她的客户。
Yes. And it's the thing where it's like, she's really trying to walk a line. Yes. Of remaining a truthful person, but also flattering you, but making sure you don't feel flattered and you call her out, you're like, don't patronize me, Pam. Oh, I know.
Yes. And it's the thing where it's like, she's really trying to walk a line. Yes. Of remaining a truthful person, but also flattering you, but making sure you don't feel flattered and you call her out, you're like, don't patronize me, Pam. Oh, I know.|||是的。而且这正是那种微妙之处，她真的在走钢丝。是的。既要保持真诚，又要奉承你，但又要确保你不会觉得被拍马屁，而你直接指出了这一点，你说：别用这种居高临下的态度对我，潘。哦，我知道。
It's so good. And I'm like, I'm sorry. I don't like it. I like it. I do. I like it. And then you're like, I like how Astrid writes her name. And Jan's like, I wrote it.
It's so good. And I'm like, I'm sorry. I don't like it. I like it. I do. I like it. And then you're like, I like how Astrid writes her name. And Jan's like, I wrote it.|||太精彩了。而我说：对不起。我不喜欢这个。我喜欢。我真的喜欢。我喜欢。然后你说：我喜欢阿斯特丽德写自己名字的方式。而简说：那是我写的。
She made it look like a little kid. Jen takes everything. I know. Okay, ready? Yes. Mommy. Oh, this. You are princess.
She made it look like a little kid. Jan takes everything. I know. Okay, ready? Yes. Mommy. Oh, this. You are princess.|||她写得像个小孩子一样。简把所有功劳都揽下。我知道。好了，准备好了吗？是的。妈妈。哦，这个。你是小公主。
Mommy. That's so much at the end. It's so crazy. I love this, like, ridiculous. I mean, you can tell I did that in one take. That was literally like, just sing it. It's just me singing, making it up. I never thought in a million years I'd have to ever sing that for anyone ever again.
Mommy. That's so much at the end. It's so crazy. I love this, like, ridiculous. I mean, you can tell I did that in one take. That was literally like, just sing it. It's just me singing, making it up. I never thought in a million years I'd have to ever sing that for anyone ever again.|||妈妈。最后那句太多了。太疯狂了。我喜欢这种……荒谬。我是说，你们能听出来我那是把一气呵成录完的。字面意思就是，直接唱就行了。那完全就是我一边唱一边现编的。我做梦也没想到这辈子还需要再为任何人唱这首歌。
Oh my goodness. It's not even a followable melody, really. It's really not even a followable melody. And now knowing that you made it up, it makes sense too, because it's like you're kind of just commenting, like, on the picture. Like she's putting on the shoe, and it's too big for her. See, that's another thing that Greg wrote in because Mindy did it first, because I sang, I did Les Mis at the Hollywood Bowl, and I was Fantine.
Oh my goodness. It's not even a followable melody, really. It's really not even a followable melody. And now knowing that you made it up, it makes sense too, because it's like you're kind of just commenting, like, on the picture. Like she's putting on the shoe, and it's too big for her. See, that's another thing that Greg wrote in because Mindy did it first, because I sang, I let's Mis at the Hollywood Bowl, and I was Fantine.|||我的天哪。那根本不是一条能让人跟着哼唱的旋律。真的完全不是一条能跟唱的旋律。现在知道那是你现编的，这就说得通了，因为感觉你当时就好像是在对照片进行即兴点评。就像照片里她正在试穿鞋子，而鞋子对她来说太大了。看，那是格雷格写进去的另一个梗，因为明迪（Mindy）先开了头，因为我在好莱坞露天剧场（Hollywood Bowl）演过《悲惨世界》，我演的是芳汀（Fantine）。
And that literally that next episode, Mindy was like, you're going to be singing. If you can sing like that, you're going to sing. And that was when I did the baby shower episode where I came in and sang to the baby, son of a preacher man. Amazing. And that was Mindy that wrote that. And then Greg was like, we're going to have her be. And then had me come in and do the Astrid song, the mommy, you know, what did you learn? You know, I learned about clocks.
And that literally that next episode, Mindy was like, you're going to be singing. If you can sing like that, you're going to sing. And that was when I did the baby shower episode where I came in and sang to the baby, son of a preacher man. Amazing. And that was Mindy that wrote that. And then Greg was like, we're going to have her be. And then had me come in and do the Astrid song, the mommy, you know, what did you learn? You know, I learned about clocks.|||就在那之后的下一集里，明迪就说：你要唱歌。如果你能那样唱歌，你就要在剧里唱。那就是我拍《迎婴派对》那一集的时候，我走进屋里对着宝宝唱了那首《传教士的儿子》（Son of a Preacher Man）。太棒了。那是明迪写的剧本。然后格雷格就说：我们要让她唱。接着他就让我来唱阿斯特丽德那首歌，“妈妈，你知道的，你学到了什么？我知道了时钟。”
And as another one that I improvised, they just gave me the lyrics. And I just made it up. And never thinking in a million years, anybody would get, you know, attached to that song. But people know these songs. I'm always amazed by the fans. And also threat level midnight. Yes. Oh, yes, exactly.
And as another one that I improvised, they just gave me the lyrics and they were just made it up. And never thinking in a million years, anybody would get, you6 know, attached to that song. But people know these songs. I'm always amazed by the fans. And also threat level midnight. Yes. Oh, yes, exactly.|||这也是我即兴发挥的另一首歌，他们只是把歌词交给我，然后我就现编了出来。我做梦也没想到这辈子会有人对那首歌产生感情。但人们确实知道这些歌。粉丝们总是让我惊叹。还有《午夜威胁级别》。是的。哦，对，完全正确。
Where you get to play the singer. Yes, exactly. I mean, that was all Greg sort of making my dreams come true. He's such a sweetheart that way. Like he's like, oh, you know, you sing. We're just going to keep on putting you in here singing all these different ways. But they did that. They were like, oh, Ed, you play banjo, it's going in.
Where you get to play the singer. Yes, exactly. I mean, that was all Greg sort of making my dreams come true. He's such a sweetheart that way. Like he's like, oh, you know, you sing. We're just going to keep on putting you in here singing all these different ways. But they did that. They were like, oh, Ed, you play banjo, it's going in.|||你在里面扮演歌手。是的，完全正确。我是说，这完全是格雷格在帮我实现梦想。他真的是个大好人。他会觉得，哦，你会唱歌啊。那我们就不断安排你以各种不同的方式在剧里唱歌。他们确实这么做了。他们会说，哦，艾德（Ed），你会弹班卓琴，这个得加进剧里。
That's right. Oh, Ray, you can play recorder. Yes. It's going in. Like, just any talent that you have. They just threw it in there. Like, oh, John Krasinski, your great impressions. In.
没错。噢，雷，你会吹竖笛。是的。这就放进去了。就像，你有什么才华。他们就直接把它加进去了。就像，哦，约翰·卡拉辛斯基，你太会模仿了。加进去。
Yes. You know the one, though? I used to always say, guys, can you please, like, have Meredith built out a song sometime and be really amazing? But they were like, it doesn't track for Meredith. But Kate Flanelius is such a great voice. She did get to sing with Pam. Like, you guys got to sing. We did get to sing karaoke.
是的。不过你知道哪个吗？我以前总是说，伙计们，你们能不能，比如说，让梅雷迪思什么时候写首歌，然后表现得非常惊艳？但他们觉得，这不符合梅雷迪思的风格。不过凯特·弗兰纳里嗓音真好。她确实有机会和帕姆合唱。就像，你们俩得唱歌。我们确实得唱卡拉OK。
That's true. But, yeah. Well, karaoke is kind of perfect for her character. It is. And they found a way. Yeah, exactly. It's like, I'm a dancer. too, but I had to pretend not to dance when I'm dancing to the Hunter song.
这倒也是。不过，是的。好吧，卡拉OK对她的角色来说简直绝配。确实如此。他们找到了方法。对，没错。就像，我也是个舞者，但当我在亨特的歌声中跳舞时，我不得不假装自己不会跳舞。
You know, there's things you have to do for your character. It would have been weird for Jan to be good at dancing. And I tried to dance like literally off the beat a little bit. I tried to like, when he's doing this, I was just a little like so in the reverie of the sex of the sex of the song and the memory of the sex. Dancing in that moment is so great. And you'll remember this, Angela, because we were there, which is that you walked over to John and you were like, like, dance with me.
你知道的，有些事你必须为角色去做。让简擅长跳舞会显得很怪。我试着跳得，字面意义上，有点跟不上拍子。我试着像，当他这样做的时候，我有点像完全沉浸在那首歌带来的性幻想、性爱的回忆中。那一刻的舞蹈太棒了。安吉拉，你会记得这个的，因为我们当时就在现场，那就是你走到约翰面前，对他说，就像，和我一起跳舞。
And he was so brilliant because he didn't, but you then awkwardly, like, spin yourself under his seated arm. So weird. It's just incredible. Oh, my God. It was so much fun. We haven't talked about us breaking in scenes yet, but we need to. But when you're singing son of a preacher man,
他太机智了，因为他没动，但你随后却尴尬地，从他坐着的手臂底下转了个圈。太诡异了。简直绝了。哦，天哪。太好玩了。我们还没聊过我们在片场笑场的事呢，但我们得聊聊。但当你在唱《传教士之子》时，
I'm sitting right behind you at that baby shower. And what I wasn't ready for was when you, while holding the baby and you're sitting on the ground, you started snapping. Like, it just started like you were so feeling it and everyone is just watching you. And when you started snapping, I thought, I'm going to lose it. I am going to lose it. Oh, my gosh. Well, it was such a free environment for those kinds of things, you know, because I think the snapping, it was just something that came to me in the moment.
我就坐在你身后的婴儿送礼会现场。而我完全没料到的是，当你抱着婴儿坐在地上时，你开始打起了响指。就像，你突然开始打响指，仿佛你完全沉浸其中，每个人都在看着你。当你开始打响指时，我想，我要失控了。我快要笑崩了。哦，天哪。好吧，那种氛围真的很自由，你知道的，因为我觉得打响指，只是我当时灵光一现的想法。
It wasn't like I planned that or thought that through the night before. So we're very lucky that we had that experience. It really is very special and not always that way. It's not always an environment where that many people can make that much space for each other. People often ask how it was working with Steve. What was it like to work with Steve Karell? And I always say, well, the best thing about that was just that space that we made for each other. That really was very present.
这并不是我前天晚上计划好或深思熟虑过的。所以我们很幸运能有那种经历。那真的很特别，而且并非总是如此。那并不是那种每个人都能为彼此腾出那么多空间的氛围。人们经常问和史蒂夫合作是什么感觉。和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作是怎样的体验？而我总是说，嗯，最棒的事情就是我们为彼此创造的那种空间。那真的很真实，而且大家都全身心投入。
And we had also a great connection. To finish that question, what would I like? like an episode to go longer, where would I have like to have gone more depth. I would say the end of the dinner party episode was so strong with her trying to put the thing back together. Yes. The Dundee. Yeah. The Dundee back together. And just what had gone on that night and how deep and revelatory that was for their insight into their relationship that I think I did for a long time have thoughts of where that could have gone had they continued the relationship. There were a lot of things I think could have come from that. I even had conversations with Greg
而且我们之间的默契也很好。顺着刚才那个问题回答，如果我想让某一集时间更长，或者想在哪集里深入挖掘，我会说“晚宴派对”那一集的结尾太棒了，她试图把那个东西拼回去。没错。那个小金人。是的。把小金人拼回去。还有那天晚上发生的一切，对于他们洞察彼此的关系是多么深刻且具有启示意义，我想很长一段时间里，我都一直在想，如果他们继续这段关系，那会走向何方。我觉得有很多事情都可以由此展开。我甚至和格雷
about it, I think, about like where it could go from there. And so I was, I think I was a little like, oh, we could have done so much more like together as a little couple and, you know, could have been even crazier and fun and we could have healed and we could have, you know, blown up. And so yeah, that's where I would say I could have gone. I could have gone more with that. Yeah. Yeah.
聊过这件事，关于它接下来可以怎么发展。所以我想我当时有点像，哦，我们本可以像一个小两口一样一起做更多事情，而且，你知道的，可能会更疯狂、更有趣，我们本可以治愈彼此，我们本可以，你知道的，彻底爆发。所以，是的，这就是我会说我可以深入挖掘的地方。我可以把那条线演得更深入。是的。是的。
Yeah, because. Yeah, but Michael just ends up, you guys kind of break up. Yeah. And he moves in with Dwight at the farm. Right. And then we don't see you for a while. Yes. Yes.
对，因为。是的，但迈克尔最后，你们俩算是分手了。是的。然后他搬去农场和德怀特同住了。对。然后好长一段时间我们都没再看到你。是的。是的。
But I hear you in terms of it did feel like we had just scratched the surface and how fun it was to go into Michael's private home with jazz. Oh my gosh. And into that relationship. that we'd only seen in little glimpses at the office. Yeah. I mean, I could have spent a whole season just in that condo. Exactly.
但我明白你的意思，感觉我们确实只是触及了皮毛，能带着简走进迈克尔的私人住宅是多么有趣啊。哦，天哪。还有走进那种我们在办公室里只能窥见冰山一角的恋爱关系。是的。我是说，我可以在那间公寓里拍整整一季。没错。
I mean, I could have watched a spinoff that was Jan in some kind of neighborhood group chat. I mean, what was Jan like in that condo community? I could have watched that. No, that could have been good. That could have been good. I loved it when Michael, like, she wants the car because she's going to yoga, the one car they share, and he's working as a telemarketer and she doesn't know it and all this stuff. But you go to pick him up and he's like, how was you okay?
我是说，我可以看一部衍生剧，讲的是简在某种社区业主群里的故事。我是说，简在那个公寓社区里是什么样的？我绝对会看。不，那肯定很棒。那绝对会很棒。我特别喜欢迈克尔，比如，她想要车因为她要去上瑜伽课，他们共用的一辆车，而他却在当电话推销员，她还不知道这事，诸如此类的种种。但你去接他，他却说，你没事吧？
Jan goes, I didn't go. And she was like, you drive. I drink too much wine. I was like, I want to see more of Jan's life. It's so amazing to me. Oh, it is. It's so silly. So silly.
简说，我没去。然后她说，你来开。我喝了太多酒。我就觉得，我想看更多关于简的生活。这对我来说太神奇了。哦，确实如此。太荒谬了。太荒谬了。
Oh, well, I'm here for the Jan spin-off. I can tell you that. Okay, so I have to ask you because a bunch of people did write in. about this. Because you had so many scenes with Steve, was there one in particular that you remember that was so difficult to get through because you were laughing? And I know one that you're heavily featured in the blue person. Well, I mean, obviously the one in the dinner party where he kept throwing the television, that he kept the Dundee, and when he kept saying about the small TV and this size and pulling it out of the wall, just like, it was ridiculous. That was ridiculous.
哦，好吧，我是简的衍生剧的死忠粉。我可以这么告诉你。好了，我得问你一个问题，因为很多人写信来问这个。因为你和史蒂夫有那么多对手戏，有没有哪一场是你觉得特别难演过去，因为你们一直在笑？我知道其中一场有你的特写，就是那个气氛诡异的。好吧，我的意思是，很明显是在晚宴派对上那一幕，他不停地扔电视，他留着小金人，当他不停地说那个小电视有多大、尺寸是多少，还把它从墙上拽下来，简直是，太荒谬了。那太荒谬了。
None of us could get through that. Jenna, you couldn't get through that. I couldn't get through that. John couldn't get through that. It was mostly the three of us, right? Yeah. That was before Andy and Angela arrived and we were getting the house tour. But even Steve broke in that. And he never breaks.
我们谁都演不下去。珍娜，你演不下去。我也演不下去。约翰也演不下去。主要就是我们三个，对吧？对。那是安迪和安吉拉到达之前，我们正在参观房子的时候。但连史蒂夫在那场戏里都笑场了。他从不笑场的。
And I really didn't break very much. I don't think I'm, I don't know if I'm in the bluer. You didn't. You didn't break much. You were good. No, I didn't laugh that much. But like I could not get through that stupid television. And also you, when I come up to the thing to knock on the door,
而我其实很少笑场。我觉得我，我不知道我是不是在那个气氛诡异的片段里。你没有。你没怎么笑场。你表现得很好。不，我没笑得那么厉害。但我就是无法演过那个愚蠢的电视机。还有你，当我走过去准备敲门时，
the bathroom and you and John are in the bathroom? Well, we're up in the hallway, I think. Oh, in the hallway. I'm eating. You're eating. And this didn't even make it in the episode. Yeah, because the Asabuco wasn't ready yet. Yes, and I'm eating and I had to keep, you know, because every time we broke, we had to
浴室门，你和约翰在浴室里？哦，我们在走廊上，我想。哦，在走廊上。我在吃东西。你在吃东西。这甚至都没剪进正片里。对，因为牛尾汤还没做好。是的，我在吃东西，我不得不一直，你知道的，因为每次我们笑场，我们都得
retake it. I was like, you guys, I'm getting really full. Like, I can't eat anymore in this power bar. I feel like you were in the bathroom because I felt like we had to keep opening a door. Were we not in a bathroom? There was a second one, I think, where I'm in the bathroom and you. had to knock on the door. Okay.
重拍。我当时想，伙计们，我真的吃饱了。拜托，我再也吃不下这根能量棒了。我觉得你在浴室里，因为我觉得我们得一直开门。我们当时难道不在浴室里吗？还有第二个场景，我想，我呆在浴室里，而你
That I don't think ever saw the light of day. No. All of these. And every time the door opened, you or me, one of us would just crack up so much so. Now, you know it's bad because the first few times the whole crew cracks up with you. Right. But you know it's bad when the crew stops laughing. Stop laughing.
得敲门。好吧。那场戏我觉得从来没重见天日过。没有。所有这些。而且每次门一开，你或者我，我们中的一个人就会笑得前俯后仰。现在，你知道情况有多糟了吧，因为前几次整个剧组都会陪着你们一起狂笑。对。但当剧组都不笑了，你就知道事情大条了。别笑了。
Because they're just trying to get you to stop laughing so they could get through the scene. I'm Jenna. We, it was like 15, 20 minutes. Because it was so many. We could not stop. Well, there was this whole runner that you don't really see in the episode. It ended up getting kind of cut out, which was that like Pam was always trying to sneak away. Yes.
因为他们只是想让你们别笑了，好把这场戏拍完。我是珍娜。我们，拍了大概15、20分钟。因为有太多条了。我们根本停不下来。好吧，还有一个很长的小插曲你在正片里其实看不到。最后算是被剪掉了，那就是帕姆总想偷偷溜走。是的。
She was starving. But you were just always right on top of her. And so it was like she couldn't. The hostess with the most is monster. Yes. Without food. Yes. That whole idea was so funny to us.
她快饿死了。但你总是阴魂不散地盯着她。所以就好像她根本无法。热情好客的女主人简直是个怪物。是的。没有食物。是的。整个这个创意对我们来说太搞笑了。
Oh, God. Because it was like a horror movie. It was like, yeah. Exactly. You were just trying to get a snack. I have some things downstairs. It was so good. I was at a restaurant in Seattle last week, and there was Osabucco on the menu.
哦，天哪。因为这就像一部恐怖电影。这就好像，对。没错。你只是想找点零食吃。我楼下有些吃的。太棒了。我上周在西雅图的一家餐厅，菜单上有牛尾汤。
Which is delicious. And the waiter said to me, are you going to get the postage of a little wink, wink? And I thought, oh, my gosh, I bet Melora gets this all the time. Like, is there a quote? We had a guy write in, Amelia S from Yukon. on Oklahoma, what is one line that gets quoted to you the most? Oh, my gosh. I guess that if you burn it, you buy it is sort of what people tend to say to me.
那道菜非常美味。服务员对我说，你要点那个小金人吗？还带着一个小小的挤眉弄眼。我想，哦，天哪，我敢打赌梅洛拉经常遇到这种事。比如，有没有什么台词？有个叫阿米莉亚·S的粉丝从俄克拉荷马州育空地区写信来问，哪句台词是别人对你引用最多的？哦，天哪。我想，大概是“如果你把它烧了，你就得买下它”这种话吧，人们往往会对我这么说。
Or I guess that makes me the devil. Oh, I bet you get that. That one. That's what she said. That's the one I hear the most, obviously, right? It's like everyone says, you say something and they say, oh, that's what she said, or they say something and, oh, that's what she said. Yeah.
或者我想这让我变成了魔鬼。哦，我敢打赌你经常听到这个。那句。这就是她说的。这是我听到最多的，很显然，对吧？就像每个人都会说，你说了句什么，然后他们就会说，哦，这就是她说的，或者他们说了句什么，然后，哦，这就是她说的。是的。
I thought the best, that's what she said, that I watched, all your clips is when they, when Michael says it in the deposition. The dying star. Oh, I thought you were going to say the cocktail episode. Oh, no, that is brilliant. That was a great moment of that's what she said. I'm like, I guess I'll just get back with Michael and dissolve inside myself like a dying star. That's what she said. That is. And it makes no sense. It's not a that's what she said. Jan's using it wrong. And she doesn't even know what she's saying and she's a little confused by it. It's such a freaking great. That's really fun. I think there is a handle that leads to that's what she said. Is there not?
我觉得最棒的“这就是她说的”，我看过的你所有的片段里，就是当迈克尔在听证会上说出这句话的时候。垂死的恒星。哦，我还以为你会说鸡尾酒那一集呢。哦，不，那太绝了。那是“这就是她说的”的高光时刻。我当时想，好吧，我想我还是跟迈克尔复合算了，然后像一颗垂死的恒星一样在内心深处瓦解。这就是她说的。确实如此。而且毫无逻辑。这根本不是一处“这就是她说的”的梗。简用错了。而且她甚至不知道自己在说什么，她自己对此还有点糊涂。简直太棒了。真的很有趣。我觉得有一个相关的话题梗就是“这就是她说的”，对吧？难道不是吗？
Is it? No, here, I have it. I have it because, Malora, I have to tell you that there is a Dundermifflin Reddit thread and they put this prompt, one line that best captures a character and this is what they wrote for Jan, which is from cocktails. It's, I'm taking a calculated risk. This is the upside. I overcome my nausea, fall deeply in love. Babies, normalcy, no more self-loat. Downside, I date Michael Scott publicly and collapse him on myself like a dying star. Why is this so hard? That's what she said. Oh, my God.
是吗？不，我有，我有。因为，梅洛拉，我必须告诉你，有一个关于《办公室》的Reddit讨论串，他们出了这样一个命题：最能捕捉一个角色精髓的一句台词，而他们为简写下的就是这句，出自《鸡尾酒》那一集。就是，“我在冒着经过计算的风险。这就是好的一面。我克服了恶心，深深坠入爱河。宝宝，正常的生活，不再自我厌恶。坏的一面，我和迈克尔·斯科特公开约会，然后像一颗垂死的恒星一样在他身上崩溃瓦解。为什么这么难？这就是她说的。”哦，天哪。
Why is this so hard? That's what it is. That's what she said. Okay. There was a setup. But people think that perfectly encapsulates the character of Jan. It does. It does.
为什么这么难？原来是这样。这就是她说的。好吧。这本是个铺垫。但人们认为这完美地概括了简这个角色。确实如此。确实如此。
No, it's really perfect. And it was quite early in the show. Yes, season three. Uh-huh. Yeah. Well, before we let you go, you've been so generous. we got some fan mail flurries. People had questions about some non-office-related things. Okay.
不，真的很完美。而且那是在剧集很早的时候。是的，第三季。嗯哼。对。好吧，在我们让你离开之前，你真是太慷慨了。我们收到了一波粉丝来信。大家对一些和《办公室》无关的事情有一些问题。好的。
So a lot of people are curious how the recasting of Back to the Future affected you and how you persevered. Well, I was 17 years old, and it was a big deal because it was a two-picture deal. And it was Bob Zemeckis and Bob Gale and Eric Stolt, who I had a huge crush on. we had almost worked together several times. And at that time in my life, I just had a huge crush on him. So I was super excited to do this. Went and did, you know, publicity photos. It was on the back lot at Universal.
所以很多人好奇《回到未来》重新选角对你有什么影响，你是如何坚持下来的。好吧，我当时17岁，这绝对是一件大事，因为这是一份两部电影的合约。那是罗伯特·泽米吉斯、罗伯特·加尔和埃里克·斯托尔茨，我当时超级迷恋他。我们差点合作了好几次。而在我当时的人生阶段，我就是极其迷恋他。所以我对此超级兴奋。去拍了，你知道的，宣传照。那是环球影业的片场外景地。
It was a big, big movie. It was a big deal. Had you shot anything? Did you? I didn't know. We should say, like he was Marty McFly and then you were Jennifer. Yes. Uh-huh.
这是一部非常、非常大的电影。这是一件大事。你当时拍了什么吗？你拍了吗？我不知道。我们应该说明一下，他当时是马蒂·麦克弗莱，而你是詹妮弗。是的。嗯哼。
Yeah. Okay. Yes. And it was all things. I mean, it was like it was a go. You were doing marketing for it. Yeah. So I had only done some publicity stuff.
是的。没错。而且一切都敲定了。我的意思是，项目已经正式启动了。你当时在为它做市场宣传。对。所以我当时只做了一些宣传方面的工作。
I had done some costume fittings. And I had met everyone. I'd come on the set and the back lot there on Universal. You know, I was part of it. It was fun. And I was excited. And I was starting like a week later, you know. And then, yeah, got a call.
我试穿过戏服。而且我都见过大家了。我去过环球影业的片场和外景地。你知道的，我是其中一员。那很有趣。我很兴奋。而且我大概一周后就要开拍了，你知道的。然后，是的，接到一个电话。
I remember in my mom and dad's kitchen in our house in the valley. It was, you know, a wall phone. There were no cell phones. And I remember my mom answering and saying, oh, honey, this is free. you and she was standing there next to me and Bob Gale and Bob Zemeckis were on the phone together and they both just said, you know, this is just the most awful phone call I've ever had to make and we just think you're amazing and we disagree, but apparently some of the executives at Universal, you know, we've had to let Eric Stoltz go and they feel like it's emasculating to their lead
我记得是在山谷区我们家我爸妈的厨房里。那是一部，你知道的，挂在墙上的电话。那时候还没有手机。我记得我妈妈接了电话说，哦，亲爱的，这是找你的。她就站在我旁边，罗伯特·加尔和罗伯特·泽米吉斯一起在电话里，他们俩就说，你知道的，这是我这辈子打过最糟糕的电话，我们都觉得你太棒了，我们意见不一，但显然环球影业的一些高管，你知道的，我们不得不辞退埃里克·斯托尔茨，他们觉得让男主角有一个比他个子还高的女朋友会有损男主角的男子气概，而你比我们新雇的迈克尔·福克斯要高出不少。所以我们不想这么做，但我们不得不辞退你。对此我们感到非常难过。我当时就泪崩了。我一下子就泪崩了。我的意思是，我当时简直是泪如泉涌。他们给我寄了我这辈子见过最美丽的鲜花。它，就像，摆满了一整张桌子。而且，你知道的，我当时才17岁。所以你该怎么办？你如何继续生活？你只能继续生活，你知道的，很多人没有意识到，作为演员，我们不仅要擅长我们的工作，我们还必须是非常坚韧的人。而且你还必须坦然接受所有的失败。我开过大师班，或者我，你知道的，教过一些东西，或者演过一些演出，
actor to have a girlfriend that's taller than him and you are quite a bit taller than Michael Fox, who we've hired. And so we don't want to, but we're going to have to let you go. And we're just so sad about it. And I burst into tears. I burst into tears. I mean, I was just like floods of tears. And they sent me the most beautiful bouquet of flowers you've ever seen. It, like, filled this table. And, you know, and I just was, I was 17. So what do you do? How do you move on? You just move on, you know, like a lot of people don't realize that as actors, we're not just good at what we do, we have to also be very resilient people. And you also have to be okay with all of the failure. I've done some masterclasses or I've, you know, taught some things or done shows and
人们会问我，特别是年轻人，你是如何走到今天的？而我总是说，我要想走到今天，我经历的失败一定比成功多得多。没有失败，绝无可能取得我今天这样的成功，也无法成为今天的我。我们现在生活在一个极度痴迷于成功的世界里，如此痴迷于每个人生活中时时刻刻都在发生的那些惊艳的事情，以及社交媒体上呈现出的画面。这不仅与真实情况不符，而且对我们身为人类的成长也毫无益处。对我们人类来说，经历失败至关重要。顺便说一句，我们绝不是通过成功产生共鸣的。我们彼此相连。
people ask me, you know, how do you get to be where you are, especially young people? And I always say, for me to be where I am, I would have had to have failed much more than I've succeeded. There is no way to be as successful as I am or to be the person that I am without the failure. And we live in a world right now that is so obsessed with success and so obsessed with all the amazing things that are happening in everyone's life all the time and the picture of that on social media. And it's just misrepresentative of not just what is true, but also what is good for us as human beings. It's important for us as human beings to fail. And by the way, we don't connect over our successes. We connect with each other.
我们是通过失败与人性产生连接的。所以，我很幸运能有一对非常棒的父母，他们基本上给予了我无尽的爱，来包容那种失望和巨大的心碎，那确实是心碎。他们陪我度过了那个阶段，他们帮我继续前行，他们允许我悲伤，他们鼓励我第二天去上舞蹈课，他们鼓励我去上学。
We connect with humanity through our failures. And so I happened to have some really amazing parents who basically gave me a lot of love for that disappointment, that huge heartbreak, which it was. And they held me through it, and they helped me go on, and they let me grieve, and they encouraged me to go to dance class the next day, and they encouraged me to go to school.
我第二周就去参加了一个试镜，然后我继续前行。我只是继续生活。这就是我们所有人都在做的。我们经历这些事情。我们不会崩溃，我们也不会变成地上的一滩油渍，你知道的，尽管我们有时可能觉得自己确实如此。你知道的，我昨天刚和一个人聊天，他说，你知道的，他
And I went to an audition the next week, and I continued. And I just went on. I went on. And that's what we all do. We move through these things. And we don't crumble and we don't become just a greasy spot on the ground, you know, even though we might think we are. You know, I just was talking to someone yesterday who was saying that, you know, he hadn't
生命中已经好几年没有谈过恋爱了，因为他太害怕心碎了。我说，我们必须去生活。你不想活在痛苦中。痛苦就像是折磨，一种低强度的折磨。你想活在那种全情投入、倾其所有去做每件事的心碎之中。然后你要冒着心碎的风险，你也确实会心碎。但我们所有人都在不断经历心碎。
had someone in his life. He hadn't had a relationship in his life for years because he was so terrified of heartbreak. And I said, we have to live. You don't want to live in heartache. Heartache is just like suffering, like a low-grade suffer. You want to live in heartbreak where you just give yourself all of yourself to everything you do. And then you risk heartbreak and you are going to get heartbroken. But we all have gotten heartbroken all the time.
我四周前刚把我的狗安乐死。我对此心碎欲绝。我一直在为这事哭泣。如果我继续聊这个话题，我可能现在就会哭出来。但我很好。我在挺过去，而且，你知道的，她活在我的记忆里。所以我希望这个故事——因为人们对这个故事真的很感兴趣——我最希望这个故事能鼓励大家去，是的，就像全力以赴地去追求一切，150%地投入。
I had to just put my dog down four weeks ago. I'm completely heartbroken about it. I cry about it all the time. I probably start crying right now if I keep talking about it. But I'm all right. I'm surviving and, you know, she's in my memory. And so I hope that story because people are really interested in that story. and I mostly hope that story encourages people to just, yeah, like go for everything, 150%.
你可能会失败，而且你有时很可能会失败。你可能会心碎，而且你有时很可能会心碎。但这并不意味着你不应该继续去承受心碎。你应该。这对我们有好处。它让我们更坚强，让我们作为人类的性格更坚强。然后我们可以把这些带到我们作为演员的工作中（如果我们是演员的话），或者带到你所做的任何事情中。如果你是个医生，你会成为一个更好的医生；如果你是个秘书，
And you might fail and you probably will sometimes. And you might get your heartbroken and you probably will sometimes. But it doesn't mean you shouldn't keep getting your heartbroken. You should. It's good for us. It makes us stronger, our character as human beings, stronger. And then we can bring that to our work as actors if we're actors or your work as anything you do. If you'll become a better doctor, if you're a doctor, you'll become a better secretary.
你会成为一个更好的秘书；如果你是个普通人，你会成为一个更好的自己，你知道吗？这就是我对心碎和《回到未来》的一番长篇大论。我的意思是，我都快哭了，因为我真的，我被你深深地鼓舞了，你所说的一切都是如此美妙的真理。那太美妙了，梅洛拉。那绝对太美妙了。是的。而且充满了真正的智慧。
if you're a secretary, you'll become a better person, you know? So there's my little rant about heartbreak and back to the future. I mean, I'm tearing up because I'm just like so, I'm so just inspired by you, but just everything you said was such really wonderful truth. And that was beautiful, Malora. That was absolutely beautiful. Yeah. And some real wisdom.
是的。谢谢。是的。我经历了成千上万小时的
Yes. Thank you. Yes. My thousands of hours of. working on myself self-examination and help and great teachers. And great parents. Great parents, great friends, great coaches. I have a great coach.
自我剖析、自我审视、寻求帮助，并遇到了伟大的老师。还有伟大的父母。伟大的父母、伟大的朋友、伟大的教练。我有一位很棒的教练。
So if I can share some of that, that's helpful. And I'm happy that it moved you. Well, another thing people asked about, I'm so curious to hear the answer to this, will it be filled with as much wisdom? I don't know. This is a hard pivot because I know the next question. So this is a big pivot. People would like to hear about your appearance on friends with the monkey.
所以，如果我能分享其中一些经验能有所帮助的话。我很高兴它打动了你们。好吧，人们问的另一件事，我太想听到这个答案了，这也会充满这么多的智慧吗？我不知道。这是一个艰难的转换，因为我知道下一个问题是什么。所以这是一个大转折。大家想听听你带着猴子客串《老友记》的经历。
With that crazy monkey that was pulling your hair? Well, there's more depth than you might think. So David Schwibber and I had been on a date. He went to Beverly High. I went to Grant High in Los Angeles. And a friend of ours had set us up. And when we were 17, we went on a date. A lot happened your 17th year.
和那只扯你头发的疯狂猴子？好吧，这里面的深意可能比你想象的要多。所以大卫·修蒙和我曾约过会。他上过贝弗利高中。我上过洛杉矶格兰特高中。我们的一位朋友给我们牵了线。当我们17岁的时候，我们约会过。你17岁那年发生了好多事啊。
Oh, God. Yeah, that's interesting. Wow, that's right. Yeah, that's interesting. And we had ended up kind of, I remember kind of kissing. I don't know if we ever did anything more than that. I think we just kind of kissed. We kind of made out a little, but very, you know, very minor makeout session.
哦，天哪。是的，这很有趣。哇，真的耶。是的，这很有趣。我们最后甚至，我记得我们好像接吻了。我不知道我们有没有做过比这更出格的事。我想我们只是接吻了吧。我们有点儿舌吻了一会儿，不过非常，你知道的，非常小儿科的亲热。
But it was very funny because when I went in for that, we had kind of remained friends. The sort of attraction didn't really go very far, but we were kind of, you know, a little crush on each other, I guess. And then David was working at the Daily Grill. And I tested for five pilots that season that he got friends. And it was the first pilot he ever tested for. Oh my gosh. Ever. And it was friends.
但这非常搞笑，因为当我后来去面试那个角色时，我们算是保持了朋友关系。那种吸引力其实并没有深入发展，但我们当时，你知道的，对彼此有点小好感，我想。然后大卫在Daily Grill餐厅打工。那一年他拿下《老友记》时，我试镜了五个试播集。而那是他试镜的第一个试播集。哦，天哪。有史以来第一个。那就是《老友记》。
And we were all so happy for him because we had just sort of transitioned into friends, you know? Sure. Into rest. And he got this pilot. It was this show. Okay. Great. I didn't get any of those five that I had tested for.
我们当时都为他由衷地高兴，因为我们刚刚过渡到《老友记》，你知道的？当然。去休息。他拿下了这个试播集。就是这部剧。好的。太棒了。我试镜的那五个角色一个都没拿到。
None of those went. So I was just an auditioning actor that season. And then I think, I don't remember what season it was. Was the second season maybe of Friends? Or, yeah, I might have. I think maybe it was the second season of Friends. Could have been the third, but I think it was. The Monkey was still around.
一个都没成。所以那个季度我只是个不断试镜的演员。然后我想，我不记得那是第几季了。大概是《老友记》第二季吧？或者，是的，我可能。我想大概是《老友记》第二季。也可能是第三季，但我认为是第二季。那只猴子当时还在。
So it was early friends. Yeah. So I think it was like the second season. And when I went in, I remember Martha Kaufman and the other producers saying that they were so impressed that in the audition, I did not mention that I was friends with David and got the part. anyway. And then when we were on the set, they were all so impressed that David and I were friends. And I've worked with animals like my whole life. Like as a kid, I did a series called Cliffwood Avenue
所以那是早期《老友记》。是的。所以我猜大概是第二季。当我走进去的时候，我记得玛莎·考夫曼和其他制片人说，他们印象非常深刻的是，我在试镜时根本没提我和大卫是朋友，最后还是凭实力拿到了角色。然后当我们到片场时，大家对大卫和我竟然是朋友都印象深刻。我这一辈子都在和动物合作。比如我小时候演过一个系列剧叫《克利夫伍德大道
Kids, that people can look that up. Good luck. And it was just like tons of animals. And then one of the highlights of my childhood career was this series called Thunder about a wild black stallion that came when I whistled, which is kind of important to this documentary that I'm going to be finishing in the next two months. I'm so excited my decade-long documentary I've been making. But people can look for that. It's called Hunter's Thunder. But my point is that I worked with so many animals on these shows as a kid that when this monkey came in, I was like, fine with him because I was comfortable with trainers. I was comfortable with animals. But this particular monkey was a bit wild. And I had just done an episode of Square Pegs with Sarah Jessica Parker, like maybe a year or two before that. And they had a
孩子们》，大家可以去查查。祝你好运。里面有成吨的动物。然后我童年演艺生涯的亮点之一是一个叫《雷霆》的系列剧，讲的是一匹我一吹口哨就会跑过来的野生黑骏马，这其实跟我接下来在两个月内要完成的一部纪录片有点关系。我太兴奋了，我拍了十年的纪录片终于要完成了。但大家可以去搜搜看。片名叫《亨特的雷霆》。但我的重点是，我小时候在这些节目里和太多动物合作过，所以当这只猴子出现时，我对它感觉挺好的，因为我对驯兽师很熟悉。我对动物很自在。但这只特定的猴子有点野。就在那之前大概一两年，我和莎拉·杰西卡·帕克合作过一集《方头钉》，
monkey on that show, which was a spider monkey too, and that monkey actually bit me. And, but it bit my finger, but it broke the skin. I mean, if that was now, everyone would be freaking out and they'd be sending you to the hospital. For whatever reason, I was just like, it's fine. Just put a band-aid on it. We just put like some alcohol and put a band-aid on it and I was fine. But I was a little tentative with this spider monkey because of that experience and yet very comfortable because of all my childhood experience. It was, you know, David really didn't like the monkey at all. Like also the thing you learn when you work with animals is you work with animals or babies. Whenever the animal gets it right, that's the one they're going to, that's the print they're going to take. So you have to be on every
他们剧组也有一只猴子，那也是一只蜘蛛猴，那只猴子其实把我咬了。而且，它咬了我的手指，还咬破了皮。我的意思是，如果换作现在，所有人都会吓疯，然后把你送去医院。不管出于什么原因，我当时就觉得，没关系。贴个创可贴就行。我们只是涂了点酒精，贴了个创可贴，我就没事了。但因为那次经历，我对这只蜘蛛猴还是有点心有余悸，不过由于我所有的童年经历，我又感到非常自在。你知道的，大卫其实非常讨厌那只猴子。同样，你从与动物合作中学到的一点是，你面对的是动物或婴儿。每当动物表现正确时，那就是导演会采用的那条素材，那是他们要保留的画面。所以你必须时刻保持百分之百的专注，因为他们会挑选婴儿和动物表现对的那一条。现在回看我看到的画面，我心想，那东西当时简直是挂在我的头发上。它离我的脸太近了。是的。而你根本不会，我当时根本没想过这个问题。我没想过如果它决定咬我或者只是吓坏了，离我的脸会有多近。
single time because they're going to pick the one where the baby and the animal do it right. And now looking at it when I've seen it, I'm like, that thing was like hanging on my hair. It was close to my face. Yeah. And you just don't, I didn't think about that. I didn't think about how close it was to my face if it had decided to bite me or just freaking. out because it was in front of a live audience and someone could have shouted. They could have laughed. They could have thrown something. You don't know, you don't know how people are going to behave. Anyway, it all went well and we were lucky and it was fine. And then the monkey was removed and we did the rest. But that's not normally how you do three camera shows. Like normally you do
因为它是在现场观众面前表演，而且随时有人可能会大喊。他们可能会大笑。他们可能会扔东西。你根本不知道，你无法预料人们会有什么反应。不管怎样，一切都很顺利，我们很幸运，最后没事。然后猴子被带走了，我们拍完了剩下的部分。但这通常不是三机位情景喜剧的拍摄方式。通常情况下你会拍完整场戏，然后喊卡，接着所有人都鼓掌，然后进入下一场。但在那场戏里，我想我们只是拍了猴子那一部分，然后就转向了另一部分。那是一个非常短的小片段，关于猴子的部分。是的，但它整个人挂在你头上。它挂在我头上。是的，离我的脸非常近。是的。现在的话，我可能会说，好吧，也许我的替身或特技替身可以代劳。
the whole scene and then you cut and then everyone applauds and then you move on to the next one. But in that particular one, I think we just did the monkey bit and then we moved on to the other part. It's a very short little clip, the monkey part. Yeah, but it's full on hanging off your head. It's hanging off my head. Yeah, very close to my face. Yeah. Nowadays, I'd probably be like, well, maybe my stand-in or stunt double could do that.
是的。我想我不会愿意，我不希望它当时离我的脸那么近。是的，没错。我那时候懂得没那么多。是的。现在你有了在片场经历过各种状况的经验。是的。各种各样的事。
Yeah. I don't think I would want, I don't think I'd want it that close to my face at this point. Yeah, no. I just didn't know as much back then. Yeah. Now you have the experience of all the many things that have gone wrong on sets. Yes. Lots of things.
是的。然后，你知道的，无知在很多方面是一种幸福。我确实，某种程度上我很庆幸自己当时什么都不知道。然后我就顺利完成了，不管怎样。结果还算不错。萨姆，我想你有一个问题要问梅洛拉。好的。
Yes. Yes. And then, you know, ignorance is bliss in a lot of ways. I do, like, I am happy in a way that I didn't know. And then I got to just have that, whatever. And it worked out okay. Sam, I think you have a question for Melora. All right.
嗨。嗨。我历来最喜欢的电影是1991年上映的《火箭手》。我大概看过100遍，200遍。哦，天哪。我最近才注意到你在里面演了那个酒廊歌手。是的。
Hi. Hi. So my all-time favorite movie, it's from 1991. It's called The Rocketeer. I've seen it probably 100, 200 times. Oh, my gosh. I just noticed recently you play the lounge singer in it. Yeah.
我想跟你探讨一下，因为这部电影是1990年左右出来的。所以你当时，几岁，21、22岁？正准备拍的时候。你是不是跟我说过你从那个片场顺走了一条裙子？好吧，让我想想。所以，乔·庄斯顿，导演，和我哥哥是电影学院的同班同学。乔曾来过我父母每年圣诞节前夜都会举办的派对。我唱歌。
I wanted to just pick your brain because this came out in 1990. So you were, what, 21, 22? just about filming it. Did you tell me you took a dress from that day? Well, let's see. So Joe Johnston, the director and my brother went to film school together. And Joe had come to my parents' Christmas Eve party, which we had every year. And I sing.
我总是在圣诞节前夜派对上唱歌，现在他们不办了。但我以前总是唱歌。我想乔可能挺喜欢我的，觉得我长得很漂亮，而且很喜欢我的声音，热爱音乐。我想他可能把我的头像拿去试镜詹妮弗·康纳利那个角色，但高管们，诸如此类的，你知道的，我想他当时想的是，我可以用她，我可以让她演。但不管怎样，高管们没，你知道的，没通过，把我的头像推到了一边。
I always sing at the Christmas Eve party, which they don't have anymore. But I would always sing. And I guess Joe kind of took a liking to me and thought I was very beautiful. and loved my voice and loves music. And I think maybe threw my headshot in for the Jennifer Connolly part, but the executives, whatever, you know, I think they, he was like, I could use her, I could have her. And whatever, executive didn't, you know, go for it and push my headshot aside.
但我认为决定权真的在乔手里，看谁能演南海歌手。我记得他打电话来说，你知道的，我有个小客串想让你来演，我会把它弄得非常特别，非常漂亮，你会从一个巨型贝壳里出场，这两首歌都会收录在原声带里，你将和詹姆斯·霍纳以及比利·梅合作，比利·梅是40年代一位了不起的编曲家，你愿意去伯班克比利·梅的家里和他一起合唱这首歌吗？他在那里有一栋房子和一个小后院录音室。我去了，我们做这事的时候他大概80岁了。我走进了他那个后院小录音室，他弹钢琴，我唱了一小段《Begin the Beguine》。他当时就说，哦，太好了。所以我想他必须通过面试认可我，而他也确实这么做了。
But I think it was really up to Joe, who could be the South Sea singer. And I remember him calling and saying, you know, so I have this little cameo I'd like you to do, and I'm going to make it really special and it's going to be really beautiful and just going to come out of a clamshell and both the songs will be on the soundtrack and you'll work with James Horner and Billy May, who was this incredible arranger of the 40s, would you be willing to go over and sing it with Billy May at his house in Burbank. He had a house and a little back studio. And I went and he was probably 80 when we did this. and I went into his little back studio, and he played piano, and I sang a little bit of begin the begin. And he was like, okay, great. So I think he had to sign off on me, which he did.
我只记得在片场的情形。我真的记得詹妮弗非常可爱，我们俩都穿了这些不可思议的礼服。服装设计师太非凡了。玛丽莲·万斯，她当时是个大牌服装设计师，而且她性格有点古怪。很多服装设计师都是这样，你知道的，就像那些拍大片的好莱坞服装设计师都是非常有意思的人物。她人很好，我们，你知道的，做出了这条漂亮的裙子。然后，詹妮弗在南海俱乐部的这场戏里也有一条类似的漂亮白裙子。
And I remember just being on set. I remember really Jennifer was lovely, and we both had these incredible gowns. The costume designer was extraordinary. Marilyn Vance, she was a big costume designer at the time, and just she was just a quirky character. So many costume designers are, you know, like that. like those big movie costume designers are really interesting characters. And she was lovely and we, you know, made this beautiful dress. And then, and Jennifer had a similar beautiful white dress also in this scene in the South Seas Club.
我记得当他们正在布置一切的时候，詹妮弗和我在周围转圈跳舞。就像我们在假装是舞伴，我们在那里跳舞、大笑。那画面很可爱。她人真的很好，我们在聊天，你知道的，我们玩得很开心。所以，是的，我只记得
And I remember when they were setting up everything and Jennifer and I were like dancing around. Like we were pretending to be partners and we were sort of dancing and laughing. And it was cute. She was just very sweet and we were talking and, you know, we had fun. And yeah, so I just remember. coming into the recording session and Billy May was there conducting the orchestra, which was quite a large orchestra. I mean, it could have been like 50 or 80 pieces.
来到录音室，比利·梅在那里指挥管弦乐队，那是一个相当大的管弦乐队。我的意思是，可能有50到80人编制。我甚至都不确定，但那是一个庞大的管弦乐队。就在迪士尼的外景片场。在一个很大的录音室里。那是一件大事。我走进去，简直是，哦，天哪。然后比利说，哦，我们马上要录制，只需把管乐部分收尾。你为什么不走进录音室一起合唱呢？你知道的，我们不会录制你的声音，但你可以跟着唱。
I'm not even sure, but it was a big orchestra. And it was over there on the back lot of Disney. And it was in the big recording studio on the back lot. And it was a big deal. And I walk in and I'm just like, oh, my God. And Billy goes, oh, we're about to do, just finish up some horns. Why don't you step into the vocal booth and just sing along? You know, we won't record you, but just sing along.
我以前从来没有和管弦乐队一起唱过歌。现在你是个歌手，不管你当时几岁，20岁还是多大，你知道的，和管弦乐队一起唱歌是一件大事。我以前从未和交响乐队一起唱过。所以我走进录音室开始唱歌。他们开始演奏。我开始唱歌。然后我突然听到“哒-哒-哒-哒-哒-哒-哒-巴”，我找不到旋律了。我简直是，因为管乐在演奏所有这些对位旋律，管乐在演奏，弦乐在演奏。我根本听不清歌曲了。我有点从麦克风前退缩了，然后就不唱了。正当我们，你知道的，准备离开时，比利说，你听起来会很棒的。我记得其中一个拉小提琴的走过来说，你刚才的声音太美妙了。
And I had never sung with an orchestra now. you're a singer and you're whatever age I was, 20 or whatever, you know, it's a big deal to sing with an orchestra. I had never sung in an orchestra. So I get in the booth and I start to sing. They start to play. I start to sing. And I just suddenly hear the da-da-da-da-da-da-da-ba. And I lose the melody. I literally am like, because the horns are doing all these counter melodies that the horns play, the strings play. And I couldn't hear the song. And I kind of just like backed off from the Mike and just stop singing. And as we, you know, we're leaving, Billy was like, you're going to sound great. And I remember one of the violinists walking by and going, you just sounded beautiful.
我当时想，真的吗？我刚刚完全迷失了。她说，你会找到调的。他们对我也能找到调充满信心。但我一点信心都没有。我当时快急疯了。所有人都离开了。只剩下乔·庄斯顿和詹姆斯·霍纳。詹姆斯在录音室里。他说，你为什么不跟我来？我们走进了录音区。所有的乐手都走了。那里只有一架钢琴。詹姆斯说，能把灯调暗一点吗？他们把灯调暗了。他直接坐在钢琴前说，让我来弹，我们一起唱一遍。他弹钢琴，我唱了一遍，然后他说，太棒了。现在我们来录制吧。我永远不会忘记那种身处那样一个房间里的感觉，你知道的，这又要让我哭了。那太美妙了。是的。哇，谢谢你。是的。
And I was like, really? I just lost. And she's like, you're going to find it. And they were also confident that I was going to find it. But I was not confident. I was like freaking out. And everyone left. And it was just Joe Johnston and James Horner. And James is in the booth. And he goes, why don't you just come with me? We go into the recording area. All the musicians are gone. There's a piano. and James says, can you just turn the lights down? They turn the lights down. And he literally sits at the piano and he says, let me just play it and let's just sing it. And he plays the piano and I sing it one time and he goes, great. Now let's record it. And I'll never forget that to be like in a room like that, you know, it's going to make me cry. It was beautiful. Yeah. Wow, thank you. Yeah. Yeah. It
这确实是一个非常特别的场景。不仅你的声音听起来惊艳，人长得漂亮，而且你的打光方式简直就像天使一样。确实如此。不，这太不可思议了。简直不可思议。是的。我想乔当时有点暗恋我。好吧，他让你光芒四射。
is really a special scene. And not only do you sound amazing and look beautiful, but the way you're lit, it's angelic. It is. No, it's incredible. It's incredible. Yeah. I think Joe had a little crush on me. Well, he made you shine.
他想让我看起来很美。而他做到了。是的，你看起来棒极了。是的。谢谢。但那真的太非凡了。从巨型贝壳里出场并走下来。我的意思是，那简直就像一个小小的，你知道的。
He wanted to make me look like beautiful. And he did. Yeah, you look great. Yeah. Thank you. But it really was extraordinary. The clamshell opening and walking down that thing. I mean, it was like a little, you know.
不可能有比这更好的时刻了。不可能更美了。是的。所以这是一个很好的问题。谢谢你的提问。这唤起了很多回忆。哦，梅洛拉，我太喜欢和你聊天了。我简直可以听你讲上一整天。
Couldn't have been a good moment. Couldn't have been more beautiful. Yeah. So that's a nice question. Thank you for the question. It brings back memories. Oh, Malora, I've just loved talking with you. I could just listen to you talk forever.
我觉得我的问题比刚开始时还要多。这太美妙了。谢谢你来到这里。谢谢你跟我们聊你在《办公室》里的时光，也谢谢你给予我们启发。这太棒了。你们做这个节目真的太棒了。你们把《办公室》的传说为粉丝们一直保留下来，这真的太棒了，因为它现在依然如此具有现实意义，我很高兴你们真的懂，明白这是一个值得继续聊下去的话题，而且你们是用在节目中建立的特殊友谊来做到这一点的。你们为所有粉丝做出了非常可爱的贡献。我只知道他们真的很感激。这不是我以前能想象自己会去做的事，但那是因为我以前不相信我们能这么火，直到，你知道的，这就是我的性格。所以你们坚持了下来。我喜欢你们对这一切会如何做出贡献有一种先见之明，
I feel like I have even more questions than when we started. This was wonderful. Thank you for coming here. Thank you for talking to us about your time in the office, but also for inspiring us. This was great. It's so great that you guys do this. It's so great that you've kept this like the lore of the office alive for people because it is still so relevant and I just am glad that you guys really got it, that this was a thing to continue
以及你们从中获得的乐趣和建立的友谊，这真的，
to talk about and that you did it with your special friendship that you created on the show. It's really a lovely contribution you're making to all the fans. And I just know they really appreciate it. And it's not something I could have ever imagined doing, but that's because I didn't believe we were hit until, you know, like, that's who I am. So you carried that. I love that you guys had some kind of foresight into how this would contribute. and the fun that you're getting out of it too and the friendship you've built and it's really,
真的非常温馨。所以谢谢邀请我。还有那场精彩绝伦的重聚。多棒的重聚啊。而且，梅洛拉，我们是你的超级粉丝。所以你的纪录片准备好时一定要让我们知道。谢谢。太好了。我们会在节目里为你宣传的。如果你想回来聊聊这个。好的。谢谢。真的太好了。我很感激。这是一部史诗级的，你知道的，我花了人生10年时间完成的作品。所以为某件事工作那么长时间可真不容易。所以我真的很感激。我很乐意在某个时刻聊聊它。这是一件非常具有治愈意义、美好的事情。所以我很乐意这么做。
really sweet. So thanks for having me. And the wonderful, wonderful reunions. What a wonderful reunion. And, Mara, we are such fans of yours. So you have to let us know when your documentary is ready. Thank you. That's nice. We'll give it a shout out here. If you want to come back and talk about it. Yeah. Thank you. That's really nice. I appreciate that. It's an epic, you know, 10-year thing that I've done with my life. So that's a long time to be working on something. So I really appreciate that. And I would love to talk about it at some point. it's a very healing, lovely thing. So I would love to do that.
谢谢。你主动提出真的太好了。好吧。我们爱你。谢谢你。谢谢你们，伙计们。爱你们。拜拜。
Thank you. That's very nice for you to offer. All right. Well, we love you. Thanks for you. Thank you, guys. Love you guys. Bye, bye.
谢谢大家的收听。梅洛拉是一位了不起的女性。我依然深深地被她所说的话所鼓舞，关于是失败和心碎连接了我们，而不是我们的成功。是的。那是一场非常非常棒的采访。是的。谢谢你，梅洛拉。
Thanks for listening, everybody. Malora is an amazing woman. I'm still so inspired by what she said about like how it's failure and heartbreak that connect us, not our successes. Yeah. That was a great, great interview. Yeah. Thank you, Malora.
也谢谢大家收听。感谢大家发来那些精彩绝伦的问题，正是这些问题促成了那场精彩的采访。下周我们有一期蛮有意思的节目。你们很多人写信说想听更多我的日记。所以珍娜就有了这个主意，她说，嘿，我们俩正好都要去旅行。为什么我们不把旅行经历写成日记，回来后读给大家听呢？所以我们照做了。伙计们，我现在就告诉你们，绝对不会让你们失望的，
And thank you. everybody for listening. Thank you for sending in your amazing questions that really helped make that interview happen. Next week we have kind of an interesting episode. A lot of you wrote in and said you would like to hear more of my journals. And so Jenna had this idea where she was like, hey, we're both about to take trips. Why don't we journal about our travels and come back and read them? So we did. Guys, I'm going to tell you right now, it does not disappoint. you're going to want to hear it. So we'll see you next week for travel journals. See you then. XOXO. X-O. Catch you later.
你们一定会想听的。所以我们下周的旅行日记不见不散。回头见。XOXO。X-O。回见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Sholes. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·肖尔斯进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《鲁珀特树》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。